THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRS OF B. M. P. AND HIGHER ED.
FOR AGREEING TO LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE TOGETHER -- IN THIS VENUE
AND THANK YOU -- TO YOU AS WELL
WHO AGREED TO PARTICIPATE AND
THE PANEL TODAY YOUR
PARTICIPATION IS NECESSARY TO
HAVE A THOROUGH DISCUSSION.
EASING THE TRANSITION OF SERVICE
MEMBERS TO CIVILIAN LIFE IS PART
OF THE PROMISE MADE TO EACH AND
EVERY PERSON WHO IS IN LISTED OR
COMMISSIONED IN THE US MILITARY.
AMONG THE PROGRAMS TO DO SO THE
GI BILL IS THE ABSOLUTE GOLD
STANDARD THE ORIGINAL
SERVICEMEN'S READJUSTMENT ACT OF
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR HELPED
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO FOUGHT
IN WORLD WAR TWO TO ATTEND
COLLEGE.
IT WAS A BENEFITS SO ROBUST THAT
IT CHANGE THE ENTIRE SYSTEM OF
HIGHER EDUCATION.
BUT FROM THE BEGINNING IT WAS
MADE CLEAR THAT THERE WERE THOSE
WHO WOULD EXPLOIT THE GI BILL
AND THE VETERANS WHO EARNED THAT.
OF MY CONCERNS WERE RAISED OVER
APPARENT CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
IMPAIR A CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR STATE
APPROVING AGENCY FOR VETERANS
EDUCATION OVER HELD THE LAW WAS
TO BE ENFORCED.
THIS CONFLICT WAS OCCURRING
RIGHT AROUND THE SAME TIME THAT
THE EDUCATION CORPORATION OF
AMERICA SCHOOLS ABRUPTLY SHUT
DOWN EARLY LAST FALL.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT LEFT APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED VETERAN STUDENTS IN THE
LURCH.
EVERY MONTH OF THE GI BENEFIT
FITS AT THAT A VETERAN SINKS
INTO ATTENDING AT DEAD AND
PROGRAM IS LOST THERE ARE NOW
WAYS TO THAT VETERANS CONVERT
COVER THEIR BENEFITS IN SOME
CASES BUT THEY ARE.
LIMITED THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM THE QUESTION
IS EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
WHY IT EXISTS AND HOW TO GO
ABOUT FIXING IT? TO BE CLEAR FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES HAVE A PLACE IN
THE ENVIRONMENT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
THE QUESTIONS FOR ME ARE HOW DO
WE ENSURE A HEALTHY SECTOR.
WHAT ARE THE SYSTEMATIC PROBLEMS?
WE HAVE TO SOLVE IN ORDER TO DO
SO AND WHO PROVIDES THE
OVERSIGHT AND HOW.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE QUESTIONS%
I HOPE TO EXPLORE IN THIS
HEARING TODAY THEIR ANSWER
SHOULD BE OF INTEREST NOT ONLY
TO VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
BUT ALSO. TO THE FOR PROFIT
SECTOR.
MANY OF WHOSE WHOSE MEMBERS
PROVIDE A GOOD EDUCATION TO
THEIR STUDENTS VETERAN.
AND STUDENTS ALIKE.
AN ENVIRONMENTAL OF HEALTHY
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WERE BAD ACTORS ARE NOT ABLE TO
EXPLOIT VETERAN STUDENTS IS OUR
SHARED INTERESTS.
THE SOONER WE AGREE ON THAT AND
A PATH FORWARD THE BETTER.
AND NOW I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY
OF THE CHAIR OF THE HI READ
PLEASE MAKE A FEW COMMENTS.
THANK YOU UP HERE IRWIN.
VERY GLAD THAT WE COULD HAVE
THIS JOINT.
HEARING.
RARELY DO WE SEE AN ISSUE THAT
SPANS THE PURVIEW OF THREE
POLICY COMMITTEES.
YET THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
VETERANS HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND HOW THOSE ISSUES INTERACT
WITH.
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
IS A RARE EXCEPTION.
THE MEMBERS OF OUR ARMED FORCES
MAKE A PARTICULARLY POIGNANT
SACRIFICE. TO THEIR COUNTRY.
THEY OFTEN WORK LONG HOURS AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS
FOR MONTHS AT A TIME.
THOSE IN THE PROFESSION OF ARMS
TAKE THEIR OATH KNOWING THAT
AMERICA IS GREAT YES.
AMERICA'S ENGAGED IN ARMED
CONFLICT AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY MAY VERY LIKELY BE ASKED TO
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
AND ARE CALIFORNIA LARGEMENT
TAKE THE EXTRA BURDEN OF
DEPLOYING THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
TO COMBAT FIRES ANOTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS SOMETIMES FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS I AM.
THE SACRIFICES ALSO CARRY WITH
THEM CERTAIN BENEFITS.
A REAL EXPECTATION THAT ONE
SERVICE THERE SERVICE ENDS THAT
ARE VETERANS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CARE.
THROUGH THE VA AND OF COURSE
ACCESS.
THROUGH THE WHEN GOVERNOR AGI
BILL IN ORDER TO PURSUE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
THE WAY I SEE IT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE BENEFITS.
ARE NOT BEING EXPLOITED.
WE HEARD TESTIMONY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS REGARDING SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT VETERANS OF
FACE.
IN THEIR PURSUIT OF A HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THIS IS NOT SIMPLY AN ISSUE FOR
OUR PRODUCT PRIVATE. FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS VETERANS OF ALSO
HAD TROUBLE TRANSLATING THEIR
MILITARY SERVICE AND TO ACADEMIC
CREDIT.
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS.
AND FOR TOO LONG VETERANS CAME
TO OUR CAMPUSES FEELING ALONE
AND LACKING A SENSE OF WELCOME
AND COMMUNITY.
THIS HEARING TODAY WILL HELP US
TO UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT HOW THE
GI BILL IS USED BY OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS.
AND HOW ARE OVERSIGHT BODIES
COORDINATE AND COMMUNICATE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT BAD ACTORS ARE
FLAG IN THAT PROGRAMS ARE TRULY
SERVING OUR STUDENTS.
FINALLY WILL HEAR TESTIMONY FROM
THOSE OF YOU THAT CAN OFFER US A
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PERSPECTIVE.
FOR AN UPDATE ON THE VETERANS
RESOURCE CENTERS AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
AND THE EXPERIENCE OF VETERANS
IN THOSE VETERANS SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
THEM. TO OUR OWN STATE SERVICE
MEMBERS AND SOME OF THIS THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR MAKING TIME TO
JOIN US TODAY.
AND WITH THAT.
I WILL BRING UP THE FIRST PANEL.
AND INVITE PROFESSOR BOB MOVED.
TO THE PODIUM [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
ONE JERRY DATA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS BOTTOM
YOUTH AND I'M A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW.
MOST OF THE MANAGING ATTORNEY
AND FOUNDER OF THE U. S. THESE
VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC AND ROLLED
IN FOR OUR HEARING TODAY I AM A
MARINE CORPS VETERAN.
WAS A MARINE OFFICER I'M ALSO
RACK WAR VETERANS.
IT IS MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO
HAVE THE UP TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- I'D LIKE TO BEGIN JUST
TALKING JUST BRIEFLY ABOUT --
PUTTING THE GI BILL IN
HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
THE ORIGINALLY BEGAN AS A HIS
CHAIR WINNER WHEN MENTION IS A
SERVICE MEMBERS WE JUST AN ACT
OF NINETEEN FORTY FOUR IT WAS
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE GI
BILL.
IT REGIONALLY INCLUDED THREE
PARTS THERE WAS AN EDUCATION
COMPONENT A VA HOME LOAN ASPECT
AND ALSO SOME UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
AND IT WAS DESIGNED AS A REMEDY
FOR THE EXPERIENCE THE UNITED
STATES -- SAWED HERE IN RESPONSE
TO WORLD WAR ONE WHERE WE HAD
LARGE NUMBERS OF VETERANS COMING
HOME AND FAILING TO MAKE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITIONS BACK TO
CIVILIAN LIFE -- THERE WAS ALSO
SEEN AS A WAY TO HAVE A TANGIBLE
THANK YOU TO OUR VETERANS FOR
THE SERVICE THEY PROVIDED IN
WORLD WAR TWO ON BEHALF OF OUR
NATION.
AND THEN TO SMOOTH THAT
TRANSITION TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
IT WAS WILDLY SUCCESSFUL IT IS
OFTEN SEEN AS ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IN OUR GREAT COUNTRY SESTRI.
IT IS CREDITED BY SCHOLARS AS
BEING INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
CREATION OF A ROBUST MIDDLE
CLASS.
IT EXPANDED HOMEOWNERSHIP
DRAMATICALLY AND PROVIDED A
PATHWAY TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
THOSE WHO WEREN'T WEALTHY AT A
TIME IN OUR COUNTRY WHEN THAT
WAS NOT COMMON.
THERE BEEN SUBSEQUENTLY RATIONS
OF THE GI BILL TO ASSIST
VETERANS FROM OUR SUBSEQUENT
CONFLICTS.
THE KOREAN WAR VETERANS ARE
VIETNAM VETERANS PEACETIME
VETERANS IN COLD WAR VETERANS UP
THROUGH THE MONTGOMERY GI BILL.
AND THEN TO TODAY THE FOREVER GI
BILL AND POSTED ELEVEN GI BILL.
HE TRANSFORMED OVER TIME --
ORIGINALLY IT WAS AS I DESCRIBED
THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO HAD
SERVED IN COMBAT.
IT BECAME MORE OF A RECRUITMENT
TOOL OFTENTIMES DURING TIMES OF
PEACE.
AND THE BENEFITS BECAME LESS
GENEROUS NOT NOT NECESSARY
BECAUSE CONGRESS REDUCE THE
BENEFITS BUT PRIMARILY BECAUSE
THEY SIMPLY DO NOT KEEP UP WITH
THE COSTS OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE POST ELEVEN GI BILL WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
THE BENEFITS BEGIN FLOWING IN --
TWO THOUSAND NINE IT WAS THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY AMENDED AS IS THE
CALL MARY ACT.
IN RECENT YEARS AND IT WAS
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE
FOREVER GI BILL MAINLY BECAUSE
THE BENEFITS WERE CHANGE THAT
THERE WAS NO LONGER A FIFTEEN
YEAR CAP ON TIME. TO USE THOSE
BENEFITS BUT INSTEAD IT WOULD
CONTINUE IN PERPETUITY FOR
VETERANS WHO SERVED AFTER.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN SINCE THE
ENACTMENT OF POST NINE ELEVEN GI
BILL MORE THAN NINETY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AND PAID OUT IN
BENEFITS TO MORE THAN TWO POINT
ONE MILLION ELIGIBLE PERSONS.
BASIC ELIGIBILITY REQUIRES THAT
A VETERAN HAVE AT LEAST NINETY
DAYS ON ACTIVE DUTY SINCE POST --
NINE ELEVEN OR THEY HAVE
RECEIVED A PURPLE HEART AFTER
NINE ELEVEN OR THEY HAVE THIRTY
DAYS OF ACTIVE DUTY BUT
DISCHARGE YOU TO SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABILITIES OR A
DEPENDENT CHILD WITH TRANSFER
BENEFITS.
DEPENDING UPON WHICH OF THOSE
CATEGORIES A VETERAN FALLS INTO
THEIR BENEFITS MAY BE PRO RATED --
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING THE
BENEFITS WITH RESPECT TO THE
POST NINE ELEVEN GI BILL ARE
VERY GENEROUS THEY PROVIDE
TUITION HOUSING ALLOWANCE
STATEMENT FOR BOOKS.
PAYMENT OF CERTAIN FEES FOR
LICENSING.
EXAMS AND ETCETERA -- THERE'S A
TOTAL OF A THIRTY SIX MONTH.
THE BENEFITS IN THE IDEA BY THE
CRAFTERS THE POST NINE ELEVEN GI
BILL WAS THAT -- A VETERAN COULD
RETURN FROM WAR.
TRANSITION TO CIVILIAN LIFE AND
PURSUE A A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
OVER THE COURSE OF FOUR YEARS
AND NINE MONTHS ACADEMIC YEAR.
AND RECEIVE A QUALITY EDUCATION.
THE MONEY CAN BE SPENT AT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
NONPROFIT OR PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS.
IF THE SCHOOL COST MORE THAN THE
CAP ON BENEFITS PER YEAR WHICH
IS CURRENTLY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THERE'S A SPECIAL PROGRAM TO
SHARE THOSE COSTS BETWEEN SCHOOL.
AND THE VA IT'S A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM BY ALL ACCOUNTS BUT
PROBLEMS HAVE ARISEN.
AND MANY OF THESE CHALLENGES ARE
NOT NEW -- SOME OF THESE TYPES
OF PROBLEMS OCCURRED WAY BACK
WITH THE ORIGINAL GI BILL --
THAT BACK IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
AND MANY OF THEM ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE FOR PROFIT
EDUCATION SECTOR AS WAS THE CASE
BACK IN.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR AT THAT TIME.
THE CREATION THE GI BILL
DRAMATICALLY EXPANDED THE FOR
PROFIT EDUCATION SECTOR.
WITHIN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS
AFTER ITS ENACTMENT.
THE NUMBER OF FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
IN AMERICA TRIPLE AND THAT IS
WITH THOUSANDS OF FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS CLOSING.
AND THE PROBLEMS WERE WERE OFTEN
MANY OF THE SAME ONES WE FACE
HERE TODAY.
THERE WERE FLY BY NIGHT SCHOOLS
THEY HAVE PROVIDED SUBSTANDARD
EDUCATION THEY WERE OVER
CHARGING VETERANS.
OFTENTIMES WE JUST SIMPLY
OUTRIGHT FRAUD.
CONGRESS REACTED WITH HEARINGS --
THEY BEGIN IMPOSING NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE THEY
REQUIRED THAT A SCHOOL COULD
HAVE NO GREATER THAN A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WHO WERE
VETERANS USING EDUCATION
BENEFITS.
WITH THE NIGHT TOWARDS TRYING TO
ENSURE A CERTAIN INDICIA OF
CREDIBILITY FOR THOSE
INSTITUTIONS.
GRADUALLY BECAME LESS OF A
PROBLEM OVER TIME IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE SUCCESSFUL
REGULATION EFFORTS AND ALSO
BECAUSE THE BENEFITS BECAME LESS
GENEROUS QUITE FRANKLY -- AS THE
BENEFITS BECAME -- LESS
BENEFICIAL TO THE VETERANS IT
BECAME LESS OF A A REASON FOR
THOSE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS TO
TARGET THE BETTER.
TODAY WE SEE THE SAME TYPES OF
PROBLEMS.
NOW WHILE EVERY FOR PRIVATE
SCHOOL IS NOT BAD.
VIRTUALLY ALL THE PROBLEMS WE
SEE AT A PLACE LIKE MY CLINIC
HAPPEN IN THE FOR PROFIT SCHOOL
SECTOR.
IN IN IT MATTERS BECAUSE SO MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS PARENTS ARE
ATTENDING SCHOOLS AT FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS -- MORE THAN 20% OF
STUDENT VETERANS HAVE ATTENDED A
FOR PROFIT SCHOOL.
APPROXIMATELY 9% OF FOR PROFIT
SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE VETERANS --
SO I TONE OF MONEY IS GOING
DIRECTLY TO THE FOR PROFIT
EDUCATION SECTOR.
ROUGHLY EIGHT OF THE TOP TEN
RECIPIENTS OF FOR PROFIT -- CITY
OF GI BILL BENEFITS ARE FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF INSTANCES
WE HAVE SEEN IN OUR CLINIC WHICH
PROVIDES PRO BONO LEGAL SERVICES
TO OUR VETERANS SERVICE MEMBERS
THEIR FAMILY.
HAVE OCCURRED AT THESE FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS AS WELL.
THE TYPES OF ISSUE WE SEE FALL
BROADLY INTO TWO CATEGORIES.
THE FIRST HAS TO DO WITH PRE
ENROLLMENT AND THE SECOND IS
POST ENROLLMENT IN THE PRE ROMAN
FACE IT'S PRIMARILY RELATED TO
PREDATORY RECRUITMENT EFFORTS.
THAT ONE IS A PRETTY TO
RECRUITMENT WHAT I MEAN IS WE'VE
HAD CLIENTS COME TO US AND SAY
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN LIED TO
ABOUT ALMOST ANYTHING YOU COULD
BE LIED TO ABOUT WITH RESPECT TO
SCHOOLS PROGRAM.
THAT MEANS VETERANS WHO'VE BEEN
TOLD -- FALSE JOB PLACEMENT
RATES.
FALSE -- SALARY EXPECTATIONS
AMOUNTS THEY'VE BEEN TOLD THEIR
SCHOOL IS ACCREDITED ONE IS NOT.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD -- THAT THEY
COULD COMPLETE THEIR SCHOOL IN A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME WHEN IT
WAS IMPOSSIBLE WE'VE EVEN HAD
BETTER INTO BEEN TOLD.
THAT THE SCHOOL COULD
ACCOMMODATE THEIR SERIOUS
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITIES
WHEN THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO DO SO.
THERE'S ALSO PROBLEMS AFTER ROLE
THAT.
WE'VE HAD DEADLINES COME TO US
WHO SAID THAT THE QUALITY
EDUCATION IS BEING PROVIDED WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY LACKING AT THAT.
INSTRUCTORS THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE TEACHING THEM DID NOT HAVE
THE REQUISITE CREDENTIALS OR
KNOWLEDGE IN THE FIELD IN WHICH
THEY WERE PROVIDING INSTRUCTION.
AND THAT THE SCHOOLS TO SIMPLY
DID NOT WOULD NOT MEET THEIR
EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT THEY NEEDED
TO BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION TO A CIVILIAN CAREER.
AND WHILE MUCH OF WHAT I
PROVIDED SO FAR HAS BEEN DATA IN
IN AND GENERAL CATEGORIES OF
PROBLEMSI THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
WE WE DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT THEIR INDIVIDUAL
VETERANS WERE REALLY BEING
HARMED -- ONE OF OUR CLIENTS FOR
EXAMPLE WAS A MARINE CORPS
VETERAN WHO WAS SEVERELY INJURED
AS A RESULT OF AN ENEMY ROCKET
ATTACK WHILE HE WAS SERVING IN
IRAQ.
AMONG HIS MANY INJURIES ONE WAS
A VERY DEVASTATING AUTOMATIC
BRAIN INJURY.
HOWEVER HE STILL WANTED TO AFTER
LEADING -- SERVICE WITH AN
HONORABLE DISCHARGE IS HONORABLY
RETIRED.
HE WANTED TO PURSUE A HIGHER
EDUCATION SO THAT HE COULD-- IN
HIS WORDS CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOCIETY.
UNFORTUNATELY HE ENROLLED AT A
FOR PROFIT SCHOOL -- THE MISLED
HIM WITH RESPECT TO WHAT TYPES
OF JOBS HE COULD RECEIVE AT THE
END -- THEY MISLED HIM WITH
RESPECT TO HOW LONG SCHOOLS
PROGRAM WOULD BE AND THEY TOLD
HIM THAT THE SCHOOL IS
ACCREDITED WHEN IT WAS NOT.
ADDING INSULT TO INJURY AFTER HE
LEFT THE SCHOOL HE CAME TO US
AND WE DISCOVER THE SCHOOL
CONTINUE TO RUN HIS GI BILL
BENEFITS EVEN AFTER HE WAS NO
LONGER ENROLLED IN THE SCHOOL --
IT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE I CAN GIVE
YOU DOZENS MORE OF INDIVIDUAL
VETERANS WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
COUNTRY HONORABLY.
RIDE TO DO THE RIGHT THING BY
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION AND
THEN WE WERE RAN INTO TROUBLE
WHEN THEY USE THOSE BENEFITS AT
FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
THE PROBLEM WITH FOR PRIVATE
SCHOOLS IS NOT ONLY WHAT HAPPENS
WHILE THE STUDENTS THERE BUT IT
OFTEN HAPPENS WHEN THE SCHOOL
ABRUPTLY SHUTS DOWN.
SO BROUGHT SCHOOL CLOSE TO BEEN
IN THE NEWS FREQUENTLY WE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE VERY.
WELL RECEIVED ARE WELL
UNDERSTOOD THIS PROBLEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT TO
CREATE THE IN BUT THERE'S
ANOTHER LARGE NATIONAL BRANDS
THAT HAVE THAT HAVE CLOSED I TT
EDUCATION CORPORATION OF AMERICA.
AND ALSO MANY SMALLER SCHOOLS --
OR REGIONAL SCHOOLS.
IN RECENT YEARS MORE THAN TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND VETERANS WERE LEFT
IN THE LURCH WHEN THEY'RE FOR
PROFIT SCHOOL CLOSED. ONE OF FOR
PROFIT SCHOOL CLOTHES IT'S
PARTICULARLY HARD FOR VETERANS
BOTH ACADEMICALLY AND NON
ACADEMICALLY.
ACADEMICALLY THE CREDIT SIMPLY
DON'T TRANSFER SO A VETERAN WILL
SEEK OUT THEIR TRANSCRIPT WHEN
THE SCHOOL CLOSES NOT ONLY ARE
THEY SLAP IN THE FACE WHEN THEY
ATTEMPT TO GO TO SCHOOL ONE DAY
AND FIND THE DOORS ARE CLOSED
IT'S SHOCKING IS THAT IS.
BUT THEN IF THEY CAN EVEN GET
THEIR TRANSCRIPT THEY DISCOVER
THAT NO THE GYM AT SCHOOL TAKE
THEIR CREDITS.
FROM A NON ACADEMIC PERSPECTIVE
VETERANS ARE HIT HARD BECAUSE
ONE OF THE CRITICAL COMPONENTS
THE POST NINE ELEVEN GI BILL IS
A HOUSING ALLOWANCE IN THE
HOUSING LOANS IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
AND IT'S PARTICULAR LIES TO THE
LOCATION WHERE THE STUDENTS
ATTENDING SCHOOL.
SO IN THE CONTEXT OF STUDENTS
ATTENDING SCHOOL IN SAN
FRANCISCO THEY MIGHT RECEIVE
MANY MORE THOUSAND DOLLARS THAN
A STUDENT WHO IS ATTENDING
SCHOOL FOR EXAMPLE RIVERSIDE.
AT THE IDEAS TO TRY TO MEET UP
WITH THE COST OF LIVING SO THAT
THE STUDENT VETERANS.
CAN FOCUS ON THEIR EDUCATION AND
NOT WORRY ABOUT PAYING THEIR
BILLS AS ATTENDING SCHOOL.
SO WHEN IS DOING BETTER IN
SCHOOL CLOSES NOT ONLY DID THEY
LOSE THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE
EDUCATION AT THAT SCHOOL.
BUT THEY ALSO OFTENTIMES LOSE
THEIR HOUSING BENEFIT AND THEN
IN BECAUSE OF THAT THERE WERE
NOT JUST ABOUT WHERE THERE'S
LIKE SCHOOLS GOING TO BE BUT HOW
THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE THEIR
PURSUIT OF A CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES.
BUT ALSO HOW THEY CAN KEEP HOME.
HOW DO YOU KEEP A ROOF OVER THE
HEADS OF THEMSELVES IN THEIR IN
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS?
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO MAKE A
STUDENT HOLE IN ANY CONTEXT WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN HARMED BY A FOR
PROFIT SCHOOL IT'S PARTICULARLY
SO IN AN ABRUPT SCHOOL CLOSURE.
THERE'S NO ONE LEFT TO SEE
THERE'S NO ONE WHO IF A STUDENT
AND WERE TO COME TO A PRO BONO
CLINIC LIKE MINE.
WELL WE CAN GO TO TRY.
TO RETURN THOSE BENEFITS TO THAT
AND EVEN IF WE WERE ABLE TO DO
SO I CAN'T GIVE THEM BACK THEIR
TIME YOU KNOW THESE ARE VETERANS
WHO HAVE ALREADY SPENT YEARS OF
THEIR LIVES IN SERVICE TO THEIR
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE READY TO MOVE ON AT
THIS POINT AND CAN PURSUE THE
REST OF THEIR LIFE AND SO AT
THAT POINT WHEN THE SCHOOL
CLOSES IN THE CREDITS CAN'T
TRANSFER ANYWHERE AND THEY'VE
WASTED THEIR BENEFITS.
IT PUTS IN AN OFTENTIMES INTO A
DOWNWARD SPIRAL WHERE THEY'RE
SIMPLY NOT ANOTHER GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM AND THEY
END UP TAKING WHATEVER JOB THEY
CAN GET.
WE'VE HAD CLIENTS WHO ENDED UP
GOING BACK TO THE SAME RETAIL
JOB THAT THEY HAD BEFORE THEY
HAD INVESTED LITERALLY SEVENTY
FIVE OR A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SCHOOL THAT CLOSED.
OBVIOUSLY THERE FOR THE ISSUE
SHOULD BE IF THERE'S FOCUSING TO
BE AND WHAT TO DO AFTER THE
VETERANS BEEN HARM SO MUCH IS
HOW DO WE STOP THESE PROBLEMS
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE I WILL
BE HOPEFULLY INTO THE THE SUBS
ONE PANELS TODAY.
ON THE OVERSIGHT ISSUES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT THE VA OUT SOURCES
OVERSIGHT TO STATE APPROVING
AGENCY SO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S R. C. SAFETY CALIFORNIA
STATE APPROVING AGENCY FOR
BETTER EDUCATION.
ARE THEY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
APPROVAL PROGRAMS OVERSIGHT OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND IN
TRAINING INDIVIDUALS RELATED TO
THOSE PROGRAMS.
THE V. A.'S OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL IN JUSTICE NUMBER OF THE
PAST YEAR ISSUED A BLISTERING
REPORT -- DESCRIBING HOW THE VA
HAS PROVIDED INADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT TO THEIR STATE
APPROVING AGENCIES.
WE FOUND THAT SPECIFICALLY STATE
APPROVING AGENCIES LACKED
EFFECTIVE SUFFICIENT CONTROLS TO
ENSURE THE PROPER REVIEW AND
EVALUATION OF PROGRAMS PROGRAM
MODIFICATION ADVERTISEMENTS.
AFTER PROGRAMS WERE APPROVED.
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER I'M GLAD
REPORT HAS A REPUTATION FOR
VIGOROUSLY DEFENDING THE RIGHTS
OF OUR STUDENTS.
THEY ARE SEEN WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY WITHIN THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY AS BEING A CHAMPION OF
PROTECTING STUDENT VETERANS AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THIS
REPUTATION THEY HAVE DRAWN THE
IRE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS.
IT IS CREATED ALL KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT I'M SURE WILL BE
EXPLORED IN SUBSEQUENT PANELS --
WHERE WHERE THE CONCERN BECOMES
TO WHAT EXTENT CAN SEE SAVE STEP
IN TO ENSURE THAT STUDENT
VETERANS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
PROTECTED AND TO WHAT EXTENT THE
DEPARTMENT AT ARMS FAIRS WILL
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN?
I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
REASONABLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE TO INSURE THAT
SEE SAFE IS ABLE TO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY THEY NEED. TO DO TO
STEP UP AND PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF THOSE WHO HAVE STEPPED UP TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF THEIR
FELLOW CITIZENS.
FINALLY IN CONCLUSION -- I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND THAT
THEY WERE HAVING THIS HEARING
TODAY I APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST
IN THIS TOPIC.
I CAN'T EXPRESS TO YOU ENOUGH
HOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO SIT
WITH THE STUDENT VETERANS WHO
HAS DONE EVERYTHING WE WOULD
WANT THEM TO DO -- SERVE THEIR
COUNTRY HONORABLY ARE ATTEMPTING
TO MAKE A SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
TO CIVILIAN LIFE ONLY TO FIND
OUT -- THAT THEY WERE DEFRAUDED
BY SCHOOL THAT TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THEM.
SAW AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
QUICK BUCK OFF THE BACKS OF
VETERANS AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
TIME YOUR TENSION AND IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS I CAN ANSWER I'D
BE HAPPY TO SEND.
I'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION WE WE
HEARD FROM VETERANS DIRECTLY --
I THINK IT BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND WE HEARD.
PRETTY HORRENDOUS STORIES ABOUT
HOW VETERANS HAD BEEN -- IN MY
ESTIMATE ALMOST -- DEFRAUDED --
IN.
BY SOME OF THESE -- BAD ACTORS --
WHAT MORE AND HOW?
CAN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
CAN WE DO -- TOOK. TO GUIDE --
VETERANS TO TO THE MOST
APPROPRIATE. FOR THE BEST
DECISIONS THAT THEY CAN MAKE.
AND GUIDE THEM AWAY FROM SOME OF
THE THE BAD ACTORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GERMANY YEAH
THAT'S A WONDERFUL QUESTION I
THINK THE I THINK ONE THING THAT
THAT IS A VERY CONCRETE WAY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE COULD DO IS
THERE IS A PACKAGE OF SEVEN
BILLS PENDING.
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY THAT DIRECT
WE SEEK TO CLOSE A VARIETY OF
LOOPHOLES THAT HAVE BEEN CAUSING
TROUBLE -- FOR STUDENTS --
RELATED TO GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RELATED TO ANTI KICKBACK
PROVISIONS -- A NUMBER OF OTHER
KIND A HOST OF OTHER DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
AND I THINK THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
I THINK THOSE ARE WAYS IN WHICH
THE STATE CAN STEP IN UNDER THE
PRINCIPLES OF FEDERALISM AND
ENSURE THAT IF THE DEPARTMENT
VETERANS AFFAIRS IS NOT GOING TO
DO ITS ROLE IN PROTECTING
STUDENT VETERANS.
THAT CALIFORNIA'S STATE
APPROVING AGENCY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DO SO -- I THINK
THAT OUR STATE APPROVING AGENCY
IS IS WILLING AND ABLE TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF STUDENT AT
ARMS THEY'RE I THINK THEY'RE
UNDER QUITE FRANKLY I THINK THE
UNDER RESOURCE I THINK THEY
COULD DO I THINK THEY DO A LOT --
FOR THE BUDGET THAT THEY HAVE
AND THEIR FUNDING GENERALLY
COMES FROM A CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AT ARMS AFFAIRS BUT
IF THEY HAD MORE RESOURCES I
BELIEVE PERSONALLY THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO MORE ON THE
AFGHAN VETERANS BY DO THINK --
RIGHT NOW IT'S WE GET QUITE A
BANG FOR THE BUCK FOR WHAT THEY
DO HAVE SO I THINK THOSE ARE TWO
CONCRETE WAYS WOULD BE EXPAND
RESOURCE FOR C. SAVE.
AND THEN ALSO -- ENSURING THAT
THOSE BILLS PASSED LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF TWENTY TWO
CAN YOU HEAR ME [inaudible]
OKAY OF SO WE'VE HAD A LONG
HISTORY WITH THE GI BILL AND
YOU'RE SORT OF DESCRIBING UPS
AND DOWNS WHAT ARE THE OVER THE
HISTORY OF THE BILL WHAT ARE THE
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN.
EVEN TO BE MOST EFFECTIVE THAT --
STOPPING THE EXPLOITATION OF
VETERANS.
THE ONE THING I SEE LOOKS OR I
THINK MADE QUITE A DIFFERENCE
WAS EVEN IN BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
GI BILL.
THE THE CONGRESS IMPOSE
REQUIREMENTS THAT NO MORE THAN A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION AT A GIVEN
SCHOOL BE STUDENT VETERANS -- SO
SIMILAR I THINK THOSE TYPES OF
REGULATIONS WORK BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES THE SCHOOL TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S ATTRACTING A DIVERSE
GROUP OF STUDENTS TO THE
INSTITUTION.
AND THAT SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ATTENDING ARE ARE PAYING OUT
OF POCKET SO FOR EXAMPLE --
REQUIREMENTS THAT NO MORE THAN A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS
BE VETERANS OR THAT NO MORE THAN
A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THE
INSTITUTIONS REVENUE BEAST
DIRECTLY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE.
RIGHT NOW IS A FOR PROFIT SCHOOL
COULD NOT DRIVE MORE THAN 90% OF
ITS REVENUE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THEORETICALLY IT
REALLY THAT'S TITLE FOR MONEY.
AND THERE'S A HUGE LOOPHOLE AND
THAT AND THAT LOOPHOLE IS THE GI
BILL IT DOESN'T COUNT ON THE 90%
FEDERAL MONEY SIDE OF LEDGER
ACCOUNTS AS IF SOMEBODY'S PAYING
OUT OF POCKET.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
SPECIFIC REGULATION LEUPOLD HIS
THAT.
IT THEN PUT A HUGE TARGET ON THE
BACKS OF VETERANS IT MAKES IT SO
THAT BETTER INS BECOME --
SOMEONE THAT IF A RECRUITER CAN
BRING IN ONE VETERAN THEY COULD
THEN BRING AND NINE OTHER NON
VETERANS IF THEY WERE CAP UNDER
THE NINETY TEN RULE.
AND ONE OF THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT THAT IS UP FOR
CONSIDERATION NOW IS A
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC WAY TO CLOSE
THAT NINETY TEMPLE SO I THINK
THOSE TYPES REGULATIONS ARE
IMPORTANT [inaudible]
AND ALSO.
YOU HEAD OF MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT WHEN THE BENEFITS FROM THE
MOST GENEROUS IS WHEN YOU HAVE
THE MOST EXPLOITATION.
AND WHEN THEY CHECK -- BENEFITS
WERE LESS GENEROUS YOU SAW THAT
DECREASE WHAT.
WHAT TYPE OF PERIOD ARE WE IN
RIGHT NOW?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I THINK
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN A GENEROUS
CARE AND I THINK THAT'S GREAT I
THINK I THINK THE PROBLEM IS
THAT -- WITH THIS GREAT BENEFIT
YOU HAVE INDIVIDUALS BY
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS WHO SEE THAT
AS A TARGET AWAY TO DERIVE
INCOME QUITE FRANKLY.
SO I THINK WE'RE IN A I THINK
ANY VETERANS ARE VERY HAPPY WITH
POSTED ELEVEN YEAH I DO I THINK
THEY THEY ARE THEY ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SUPPORT OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ENSURING
THAT THEY MAKE THAT SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION -- AND I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY -- BUT BUT I THINK AT
THE SAME TIME WE MAKE SURE WE
HOLD THE BAD ACTORS TO ACCOUNT
SO THAT THOSE BETTER IS ABLE TO
USE THOSE BENEFITS THE WAY THEY
WERE INTENDED.
RIGHT THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY [inaudible]
YOUR SERVICE.
SECONDS -- THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION THIRTEEN FOURTEEN I
INTRODUCED A BILL TO ADDRESS
THIS EXACT ISSUE -- AB.
TWENTY NINETY NINE AND WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT THE VETERANS
FROM PREDATORY PRACTICES -- AND
ALSO MAKE ACCOUNTABLE THE COOLER
DEFAULT RATE -- AT A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE AS THEY WOULDN'T
QUALIFY. FOR FOR THE THE GI BILL
OR ARTICLE THIRTY ONE MONIES.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THAT.
WELL I THINK IT'S VERY POOR
THESE LEGISLATION -- ACTUALLY
CAME UP HERE AND INTESTINE FAVOR
OF EDITION TIME SO THAT'S RIGHT
SIR -- I THINK IT'S A MORE IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE IN A PERPETUAL --
FORGET ME NOT FORGET ME YOU KNOW
KIND OF A WHEEL AND AND I'M NOT.
ARE WE DOING THINGS ARE JUST ARE
NOT BEING.
ADDRESSED IN AND IT ADOPTED OR
ARE WE GOING TO GO TO A FOUR
YEAR CYCLE AND SAY.
THAT -- YEAH IT'S NOT WORKING
STILL.
I MEAN.
WHAT WILL YOU KNOW LEGISLATURE'S
TRYING TO IT TO JUSTIN AND AND?
DO THE STUFF AND WHERE ARE
WHERE'S THE WHERE'S THE MISSING.
COMPONENT WHEN WE'RE DOING THIS
LEGISLATION IS SUPPOSED TO
ADDRESS THIS STUFF.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION I THINK.
I THINK THE PREVIOUS LEGISLATION
DID MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND I
THINK TO SOME OF WHAT I THINK IS
GOING ON HERE IS YOU HAVE --
CERTAIN ACTORS WITHIN THE FOR
PROFIT SECTOR WHO SPEND AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY.
ON LAWYERS -- WHO ARE ABLE TO
FIND WAYS AROUND THESE
REGULATIONS SO WHEN YOU LOOK
HISTORICALLY WHAT YOU SEE IS?
IT BECOMES ALMOST CYCLICAL GOING
WAY BACK TO THE ORIGINAL GI BILL
WHERE IT DAY THERE WERE ABUSES
AND AND CONGRESS IN THAT CONTEXT
STEPPED IN. TO SOLVE SOME OF
THOSE AND THEN THINGS SETTLE
DOWN A LITTLE BIT AND THEN THEY
POP BACK UP IN SO I THINK THAT'S
PART OF WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IS
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE FINDING
DEVIOUS WAYS AROUND IT.
ALTHOUGH I DO THINK IT'S MAKING
A DIFFERENCE -- THE THE OVERALL
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS ENROLLING
IN SOME OF THE WORST SCHOOLS --
HAS DECREASED SOME OF THESE
SCHOOLS HAVE GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS WHICH WHILE CERTAINLY
DEVASTATING INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
THERE AT THAT TIME -- IN THE
LONG RUN I THINK IT'S GOOD YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE STUDENTS
GOING TO SOME OF THE WORST
ACTORS FOR EXAMPLE CORINTHIAN OR
I TT OR EDUCATION CORPORATION OF
AMERICA SO I DO THINK IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE SIR -- I THINK IT'S
JUST A MATTER OF WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PULL LONG.
AND THEN ALSO JUST AS A VERY
BRIEF OUR I THINK PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS WE SAW SOME VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRESS LEADING UP TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION ROLL BACK MANY OF
THOSE EFFORTS -- HAD TO FEDERAL
LEVEL AND SO AS A RESULT OF THAT --
THERE'S BEEN NEW SPACE FOR SOME
OF THOSE WHO WHO WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF BETTER STOP RATED.
IN AND DURING THAT PERIOD
MANAGER YOU KNOW I DID A LOT OF
EXTENSIVE TRAVELING TO THE FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES IN USERNAME SOME
OF THE THE SUSPECT PLAYERS.
IN THE PREDATORY PRACTICES BUT
THERE ARE SEVERAL THAT DO HAVE
THE BEST INTENTION OF OF OF THE
VETERANS AND HEART I'M ACTUALLY
OR YOU KNOW MAKING -- STRIDES IN
SO I DON'T WANT IS COMING OFF IS
IS THERE WERE ALL ONE SIDED AND
EVERYBODY'S BAD THERE WERE ONES.
ONCE THERE WERE INSTITUTIONS
THAT WERE ACTUALLY GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND ALSO I WOULD LIKE
THAT TO BE RECOGNIZE ALSO
BECAUSE THEY ARE MAY KING THE
EFFORT. TO ADVANCE OUR VETERANS
IN TWOS YOU KNOW SUCCESS.
SO WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ACKNOWLEDGING THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
[inaudible]
PROFESSOR MOST.
VERY GOOD WORK YOU'RE DOING.
IS YOU ARE SPOT ON IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I LEFT
THE MILITARY.
IT WAS A VERY VERY MURKY AREA.
BECAUSE YOU'LL BE APPROACHED AS
A VETERAN -- I HAD A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION SO YOU WANT TO GET
SOME COLLEGE.
BUT NOW MANY VETERANS 80% WERE
LISTED.
YOU MIGHT HAVE A WIFE.
A SPOUSE.
YOU MIGHT HAVE -- CHILDREN THAT
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR NOT EVEN
BE MARRIED YOU MIGHT BE A SINGLE
PARENT.
SO THERE'S A WHOLE GAMUT THERE.
SO PART OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT COLLEAGUES.
IS MANY TIMES VETERANS HAVE
THEIR BACK AGAINST THE WALL.
IN ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
OBLIGATIONS.
THEY'VE GOT TO GO UNDER THE GI
BILL ANY WHICH WAY THEY CAN.
AND MANY TIMES ARE NOT.
PARTICULARLY -- SMART ABOUT IT.
I WAS OFFERED TO BECOME A
HELICOPTER PILOT. FOR A
GAZILLION DOLLARS.
I WAS OFFERED -- ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT WEIRD.
COURSES FROM PRIVATE SCHOOLS BUT
ON THE OTHER SIDE THE COOLING.
I WAS OFFERED SOME VERY GOOD
COURSES THEY COUNTED THAT HAD
CREDIT SO.
MY ASSOCIATE BEST FRAZIER IS
SPOT ON THERE TOO SO WHAT I'M
LOOKING AT IS LEGISLATION THAT
WE CAN DO.
NUMBER ONE THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE IN MY OPINION IS THE
COUNTY VETERANS OFFICES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
FUND THEM.
SUPPORT THEM BECAUSE THE COUNTY
VETERANS OFFICES WILL BE VALUE
WAY.
EACH VETERANS THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE THERE FOR IN A VERY GOOD
AT IT.
IN MOST CASES -- I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE LEGISLATION.
THAT WOULD GIVE EXTER.
AUTHORITY TO THE COUNTY VETERANS
OFFICES THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
ESPECIALLY TO EVALUATE THE
DIFFERENT COURSES.
AND THAT WAY WE'RE NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL WE CAN FIT EACH COUNTY
BECAUSE CERTAIN COUNTIES HAVE A
PREPONDERANCE OF NAVY MARINE
VETERANS OTHER COUNTIES HAVE
AIRFORCE OTHERS ARE ARMY. ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER THING I'D
LIKE TO SEE BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE
THIRTY SIX MONTHS OF GI BENEFITS.
IS A TIME LINE. FOR A DEGREE A
MATRIX BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
VETERANS THAT I TALKED.
TO WILL TAKE MORE THAN TWELVE
CREDITS.
SO THEY CAN STRETCH OUT THEIR
BENEFITS BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN THIS
ISN'T JUST TO GET A DEGREE. FOR
MANY VETERANS THIS IS SURVIVAL.
THIS IS THE CHECKED THEY GET
THIS IS PAYING THE RENT.
THEY'RE TELLING THEIR SPOUSES
HEY I SERVE THE GOVERNMENT'S
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF ME THEN
THEY GET RIPPED OFF AND
EXPLOITED IN A PRIVATE SECTOR
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT VERY
SOPHISTICATED I WASN'T.
IT TOOK ME FORTY YEARS TO GET
SOPHISTICATED MY WIFE STILL
DISAGREES.
SO THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NO.
IF NOT.
I WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND LET -- SURE -- WOULD
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THOSE -- COMMENTS IN
ON FOR OUR SECOND PANEL WE HAVE
A STATE OVERSIGHT THE STATE OF
OVERSIGHT REGULATION AND FEDERAL
GUIDANCE.
AND WE HAVE A TWO SPEAKERS DR
MICHAEL MERION -- THE JUNIOR
CHIEF FOR THE BUREAU OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
AND THE TONYA JOHNSON THE
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS AND CHIEF OF
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
FIRST OF ALL US HONOR AND
PLEASURE TO BE HERE MY NAME IS
DOCTOR MICHAEL MARION AS THE
CHAIR MENTION THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO BRING THIS
TOPIC WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME -- COMING FROM A VETERAN
FAMILY.
AND NOT ONLY COMING FROM A
BETTER FAMILY HAVEN'T WORKED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS.
AND IN MY LAST JOB IS TO BE US
AS THE PROVOST ASSOCIATE MUCH
PROPOSAL DREXEL UNIVERSITY.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
YELLOW RIBBON PROGRAM AND WORK
WITH VETERANS THROUGHOUT MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER I KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS.
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION AND
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSSED THE
BUREAU'S OVERSIGHT ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
SPACE PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES
TO CALIFORNIA VETERANS.
AB PROVIDES A REGULATORY
STRUCTURE FOR SCHOOLS THAT SERVE
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS STUDENTS
THAT DO NOT PURSUE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SIMILAR
PATHS BB REGULATES PATHWAYS FOR
NON DEGREE GRANTING SCHOOLS AND
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION.
HE IS A CALIFORNIA GATEKEEPER
FOR PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
ENSURING THAT SCHOOLS MEET THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS AND UP
HOLD THE ACADEMIC STANDARDS.
BEFORE STE SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT HOW BB PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
OVERSIGHT TO VETERANS I LIKE TO
BRIEFLY DISCUSS THE EXCITING
EFFORTS HAPPENING WITHIN THE
BUREAU WITHIN MY SHORT TIME OF
THE YEAR AND A HALF.
IN LATE NINETEEN IN LATE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BE VIA
UNDERWENT A RESTRUCTURING TO
CHANGES CULTURE AND STRIVE FOR
ABSOLUTE STUDENT PROTECTION.
AS A PART OF THIS RESTRUCTURING
B. B. AS MAY RE CLASSIFICATIONS
WITH VARIOUS UNITS AND RECENTLY
HIRED A SPECIAL SUPERVISOR
SPECIAL INVESTIGATOR WITH
SPECIFIC EXPERIENCE IN COMPLAIN
HANDLING ENFORCEMENT TO LEAD THE
ENFORCEMENT UNIT.
IN ADDITION TO CREATING
UNAPPROVED APPS YOU IN ADDITION
TO ALSO CREATING THE UNAPPROVED
ACTIVITY UNITS TO HANDLE
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO UNAPPROVED
ACTIVITIES.
AS A RESULT OF THESE EFFORTS
ALONG WITH THE EFFORTS OF DCA IN
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATOR IN NOVEMBER.
THE BUREAU PUT INTO PLACE
ACTIONABLE REASONABLE APPROACH
IS TO IMPROVE THE ENFORCEMENT
UNIT AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
THE ULTIMATELY EMULATING BP'S
COMPLAINT BACK LOW.
WE JOINTLY CREATED A BB
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS PPVS
ENFORCEMENT CHALLENGE.
THE BE REINFORCEMENT TASK FORCE
HAS FOCUSED ON FOR BIG AREAS.
ONE ADDRESSING THE LEADERSHIP
AND MANAGEMENT GAPS WITHIN THE
BUREAU. TO INSTITUTIONAL A PLAN
TO REDUCE THE HIGH NUMBERS TO
COMPLAINTS ORDERED AT THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS.
CREATING CLEAR EFFECTIVE
COMPLAINT PROCESSING TIMELINE
SINGLES.
AND LASTLY ALSO AS WELL AS A NEW
INTAKE PROCESS.
IN THE LAST FOUR MONTHS THE
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE HAS DONE
SOME GREAT WORK.
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF WE
CONTINUE TO THAT PROGRESS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU.
AS OF TODAY.
WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOR MINE COMPLAINTS IN THE LAST
FOUR MONTHS THAT HAVE DROPPED IN
HALF ORIGINALLY IT WAS ONE
THOUSAND AND FIFTY EIGHT IN
THESE LAST FOUR MONTHS THAT I'VE
BEEN THERE IN THE DEVELOPING
THIS TEAM WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CUT
THAT IN HALF.
AND I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE.
I'M INCREASINGLY PROUD OF OUR
TEAM IN THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE IN THE TASK FORCE.
AND CONTINUE TO DO THAT THE WORK
OF THE BUREAU THE NEW SPECIAL
ADVISER THE NEW SUPERVISOR
SPECIAL INVESTIGATOR IS WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION.
AND STAFF TO ENSURE THE AMAZING
WORK CONTINUES.
NOW AS IT RELATES TO SPECIFIC
VETERANS STUDENTS IN EDUCATION
THE BUREAU'S OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANT AND RELEASE DOES
PROVIDE SPECIFIC ASSISTANCE AND
OVERSIGHT FOR THE STUDENT
POPULATIONS.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS AREA IS ONLY BEEN IN EFFECT
A YEAR AND A HALF AND HAS DONE
SOME OUTSTANDING WORK.
SPECIFICALLY TO THE EDUCATION
CODE ESTABLISHING NO SORRY AS A
PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT TO
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION STUDENTS
WORKING IN CONSULTATION WITH
VARIOUS STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS --
SARS THE ACTIVE PARTNER WITH CAL
VETS CALIFORNIA TRANSITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM CAL TECH.
IN THE DELIVERY OF THEIR ON SITE
WORKSHOP IN DISCHARGING SERVICE
MEMBERS THAT TAKE PLACE ON
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT JACK OF A CAL VET EVENTS
ARE TO INFORM DISCHARGING
SERVICE MEMBERS OF THE VAST
ARRAY OF STATE BENEFITS THAT
WILL ENTITLE.
BE ENTITLED TO UPON BEING
HONORABLE DISCHARGE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE BY AUGMENTING THE FEDERAL
TRANSITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES OUT REACH REGARD
FEDERAL LEVEL BENEFITS.
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS AND
OPPORTUNITIES ARE ONE OF THE
SPECIFIC COMPONENTS OF THE CAL
TROUT MODEL AND A KEEP TOPIC IN
THE DELIVERY OF WORKSHOPS.
IN COLLABORATION WITH CALVET --
SAR STAFF PARTICIPATES IN IN
PERSON WORKSHOPS TO PRESENT ON A
VARIETY OF FREE SERVICES
INCLUDING THE COLLEGE FREE
WAIVERS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
VETERANS THEIR SPOUSES OR FAMILY
MEMBERS INFORMATION WHEN
CONSIDERING USING THEIR G. IDEAL
BENEFITS TO ENROLL IN A PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTION.
AS PART OF THE COLLABORATION
WITH OCR.
ALSO DISCUSSES RESOURCE
INFORMATION TIPS AND POTENTIAL
RED FLAGS TO HELP VETERANS MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS FOLLOWING THE
EVENT -- SARS ALSO ABLE TO
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SERVICES WITH
THOSE WHO EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
WORKSHOPS IN A ONGOING CASE
MANAGE THE MANAGEMENT SLASH
COUNSELING STYLE APPROACH.
ALSO HAS PRESENTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICES OFFICE ASSOCIATION IN A
POST CONFERENCE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING.
ALSO HAS ALSO ACTIVELY BEGAN
PURSUING A PRESENCE AT COLLEGE
FEARS IN TAKING PLACE ON
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS WE PLAN
TO BE PRESENT AT THE NEXT CAMP
PENDLETON COLLEGE FEAR A VERY
LARGE PROBLEM THE FEAR IN
OCTOBER.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS PART OF
THE EFFORT ALSO HAS BEGIN TO
ACTUALLY CONNECT DIRECTLY WITH
EDUCATION LIAISONS AND STAFF ON
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS TO
EXPLORE OTHER WAYS IN ADDITION
TO CAL TAP AND WORKSHOPS --
DISSEMINATE AND SHARE
INFORMATION WITH SERVICE MEN
ABOUT IN SERVICE MEMBERS.
ABOUT -- SORRY. FOR EXAMPLE
TWENTY NINE PALMS HAS A VARIETY
EDUCATION RESOURCES COORDINATOR
WHOSE WHOSE -- SEASON FOR
EXAMPLE TWENTY NINE TOM HAS A
VARIETY OF ACTIVE EDUCATION
RESOURCE COORDINATORS ON BASE TO
DELIVER A SERIES OF EXCELLENT
EDUCATIONAL WORKSHOPS WHO HOPE
TO PARTNER WITH THE NEAR WHERE
WE PROBE TO PARTNER WITH IN THE
NEAR FUTURE.
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPLORE OPTIONS
AT TWENTY NINE PALMS AND OTHER
INSTALLATIONS WAS A DIRECT
RESULT OF A CALVET SLASH --
START PARTNERSHIP.
CALVET HAS BEGIN HEALTH FELIPE
HAD A CAL TROUT HAS BE BEEN A
HELPFUL PARTNER IN CONNECTING
WITH THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE TO
MAKE OPPORTUNITIES COME TO
FRUITION.
B. B. AND STAR STRIVE TO PROVIDE
AS MUCH INFORMATION TO
DISCHARGING SERVICE MEMBERS IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM MAKE INFORMED
EDUCATIONAL DECISIONS AS THEY
MOVE TO THE NEXT STEPS IN THEIR
CAREERS IN LIFE LIKE MY
GRANDPARENTS.
IN THE FOREIGN UNFORTUNATE CASE
AN EVENT THAT A SCHOOL DOES
CLOSE ALSO ARE PARTNERS WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE PPROVING
AGENCY OF VETERANS SERVICE --
EDUCATION KOUSEI IN CLOSE SCHOOL
OUT REACH WE TRY TO COLLABORATE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH CALVET
BEFORE OR QUICKLY THEREAFTER
WHEN A SCHOOL CLOSES.
WE SHARE CAL SAVES CLOSE SCHOOL
RESOURCES FORGED A GI BILL
RECIPIENTS AREN'T SEXY SAY'S
BEHALF NORMALLY THAT INCLUDES
SEE SAVE CLOSE SCHOOL FACT SHEET
WEB RESOURCES AND CONTACT
INFORMATION.
IN LARGE IN LARGE CLOSURES THAT
HAVE IMPACT A LARGE NUMBER OF G.
I'D FUNDING RECIPIENT SEE SAY
SAYS CALMLY SENT OUT STAFF TO CO
PRESENT WITH US.
DURING THOSE ARE CLOSE SCHOOL
WORKSHOPS.
ALSO ARE COMMONLY IS THIS
VETERANS WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY CLOSURES IN FILLING
OUT A STAFF CLAIM A STRIP CLAIM.
WHICH COULD RESULT IN INSURANCE
OF A THIRD PARTY EDUCATIONAL
CREDIT.
SO THAT THEY MAY CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION ON ANOTHER INSTITUTION.
FINALLY DCA IS FOCUSED MORE
BROADLY ON ADDRESSING THE
IMPROVING THE DEPARTMENTS
INTERACTION WITH VETERANS AND
ONE OF THIS YEAR'S PROJECTS FROM
THE DC A FUTURE LEADERSHIP
PROGRAM WAS FOCUSING ON
INCREASED INCREASING THE
COLLABORATION WITH CALVET TO
IMPROVE THE RESOURCES FOR
VETERANS STUDENTS.
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THE PERSON
THAT'S LEADING THAT PART OF IT
IS OUT OF THE B. B. B. AND IT'S
ACTUALLY HERE IN THE CROWD WITH
US TODAY.
THE FINAL ITEM THAT I LIKE TO
ADDRESS IN THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN BE BEING CALVET.
SINCE COMING ON BOARD A YEAR AND
A HALF AGO I'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON
IMPROVING THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
VARIOUS.
OUTSIDE STAKEHOLDERS CALVET AND
SEE SAVE OR ONE OF THE MANY INTO
ENTITIES THAT I HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO CLAPPER WAY TO
IMPROVE CONSUMER PROTECTION. FOR
THE VETERANS OF STUDENTS.
BABY IS INTERESTED IN CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH CALVET SEE SAVE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE TO ADDRESS ANY
POTENTIAL GAPS THEN THE LAW THAT
MAY BE ADVERSELY AFFECTING OUR
IMPACTING OUR VETERANS STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA.
ALSO AMONG THE BBB IS CHARGED
WITH PROVIDING EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THESE
INSTITUTIONS IN PROVIDING STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AS THE BUREAU CHIEF THAT'S MY
GOAL AND MY FULLY AND I'M FULLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT WE
MEET THOSE AND PROTECT OUR
CONSUMERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I I A
MESSED UP A LITTLE BIT ON BOTH
INTERSECTIONS WHICH IS QUITE
SOMETHING BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT I HAVE -- MS JOHNSON'S
FULL OF OF THE RESUME HERE SAYS
ASSISTANT DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
CAL THAT AND CHIEF OF POST
SECONDARY -- EDUCATION FOR CC
THAT'S CORRECT AND THAT I WAS
GONNA GO WITH.
AND AND I AM PROUD TO SAY MISS
JOHNSON IS NOT WHILE SHE WORKS
AT CALVET SHE IS AND WAS A
FORMER EMPLOYEE OF THE BUREAU SO
SHE KNOWS A LOT OF HISTORY AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
TOGETHER SINCE I ARRIVED ABOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME -- THIS ISSUE IS.
CLOSED EVERYBODY'S HEART THAT'S
IN HERE WE SEE A LOT THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING SO I JUST JUMP RIGHT
INTO A LOT OF WHAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN SPOKEN -- KINDA IS ALREADY
IN THIS BUT I'M KIND OF READ
SOME OF THIS AND AND KIND OF SEE
IF I CAN HELP YOU.
GAME IN THE M. S. PERSPECTIVE ON
WHERE I'M COMING FROM.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE APPROVING
AGENCY FOR VETERANS EDUCATION AS
THE TORTILLAS PRESCRIBED UNDER
TITLE.
THIRTY EIGHT SECTIONS THIRTY SIX
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX SEVENTY
NINE AND CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
CODE THANKS -- TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER AND SIXTY SEVEN ONE
HUNDRED AND THREE SIXTY SEVEN
ONE OH FOUR SCHOOLS ARE THE
TRAIN OF MINERAL VETERANS MUST
OBTAIN APPROVAL FROM C. SAVING
DEMONSTRATE AND MAINTAIN
COMPLIANCE WITH APPLICABLE LAW
AT ALL TIMES.
SEE SAVE OPERATES UNDER THE
CONTRACT WITH THE US DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
WHERE BY THE VA REIMBURSES THE
STATE FOR ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CONTRACT AND ALL EXPENSES
INCURRED BY DELEGATED STAFF?
SO I WORK I HAVE A STAFF OF TEN
PROFESSIONAL STAFF AND TO
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF -- WE
OVERSEE APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
HUNDRED PUBLIC.
PRIVATE NON PROFIT FOR PROFIT
ACCREDITED AND AN ACCREDITED
SCHOOLS COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES AS
WELL AS J. T. AN APPRENTICESHIP
FACILITIES.
AND TRAINING FACILITIES.
THE SCHOOLS OFFER ALL TYPES OF
DEGREES CERTIFICATES DIPLOMAS
VOCATIONAL EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
DESIGNED TO HELP VETERANS
TRANSITION FROM MILITARY TO
CIVILIAN LIFE.
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THAT SI SE
MONITORS SCHOOLS TO ENSURE THE
SCHOOLS COMPLY WITH APPLICABLE
STANDARDS AND REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS CRITICAL TO ADEQUATELY
AND EFFECTIVELY PROTECTING
VETERANS AND THEIR EARNED
BENEFITS.
WHEN THEY'RE SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
OF WAS INSTITUTION NOT MEETING
THE STANDARDS OR REQUIREMENTS
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THE SAVE TO
SUSPEND FUTURE ENROLLMENT OF
VETERANS FOR UP TO SIXTY DAYS
ALLOWING THE INSTITUTION?
AND OPPORTUNITIES CORRECT THE
DEFICIENCIES.
HOWEVER.
THE TV A CONTRACT PERFORMANCE
REQUIRES CCA'S PRIORITY TO BE
THAT OF AUDITING PAYMENTS FOR GI
BILL.
AND NOT EDUCATION [inaudible]
YES.
HOWEVER SEE SAVE HAS TRIED TO
INSTITUTE MEASURES TO ALSO MEET
THE STATE'S PRIORITY.
OF ENSURING THAT VETERANS HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY EDUCATION AND
TRAINING.
IN SO DOING OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS SEIZE HAS EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT PUSH BACK FROM THE
DV.
EIGHT THE V. A.'S RESPONSE HAS
BEEN TO ISSUE POLICY ADVISORY IS
IN OPINIONS ACCUSING SEE SAVE OF
CONTRACT NON COMPLIANCE.
AND ULTIMATELY THREATENING TO
DISCONTINUE THE CONTRACT WITH
COLOR TO CONTRACT WITH KIND.
CALIFORNIA ALTOGETHER.
THIS MEANS THAT WE HAD TO SHIFT
OUR PRIORITIES.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE HAS BEEN THE
THREAT OF FILING OF CIVIL
LITIGATION ON BEHALF OF SCHOOLS
BECAUSE THE CEASING SUSPENSION.
OF ALTHOUGH SEE SAVE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DEFENDED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
DEVIATES RESPONSE.
HAS BEEN TO INSTITUTE POLICIES
THAT PUT VETERANS IN THEIR
EDUCATION BENNETT AND BENEFITS
AT RISK. FOR EXAMPLE.
LAST YEAR'S THE TH.
THE SAVE SUSPENDED A NUMBER OF
OUT OF STATE COLLEGES.
THAT FAILED TO DEMONSTRATE IN
ADVANCE CALLED -- THAT THEY MET
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR APPROVAL
UNDER TITLE.
THIRTY EIGHT BECAUSE OF A NUMBER
OF REASONS AYE AYE.
I HAVE LISTED THEM ALL HERE BUT
THEY'RE JUST TOO MANY -- TO
MENTION.
IT'S BASICALLY ABOUT THE WAY
THEY DO BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS WHAT THE
SUSPENSIONS WERE ABOUT.
IN RESPONSE TO SEE SAY
SUSPENSION OF THESE OUT OF STATE
COLLEGES EASIEST TV A ISSUED.
A LEVIN [inaudible]
ADVISORIES.
MULTIPLE EMAILS AND LETTERS.
TELLING US TO CEASE AND DESIST
IN EVERY WHICH WAY POSSIBLE AND
THEN THE ULTIMATE RESULT WAS TO
THREATEN AGAIN. FOR CALIFORNIA
IN ITS TOTALITY TO LOSE THE
CONTRACT.
THROUGH THESE COME IN
COMMUNICATIONS DEVIATE CLARIFIED
ITS POSITION REGARDING THE
INTERPRETATION APPLICATION
ENFORCEMENT OF TITLE THIRTY
EIGHT IT'S PERFORMANCE
EXPECTATIONS IN ORDER FOR D. ABA.
TO CONDENSE CONTINUE TO CONTRACT
WITH CALIFORNIA AND SEE SAFE. TO
ENSURE DV A CONTRACT COMPLIANCE
SEE SAVED WITHDREW THE
SUSPENSIONS AND REINSTATED THE
SCHOOLS SCHOOL APPROVALS AND NO
LONGER ENFORCES THE SAME
STANDARDS AND REQUIREMENTS.
ALL OF THIS PRACTICE LOSE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS AT RISK.
THE STATE WOULD LOSE THE TV A
CONTRACT YOU SEE SAY WERE TO
CONTINUE ITS PREVIOUS ACTIONS.
THUS LEAVING VETERANS AT GREATER
RISK.
TITLE THIRTY EIGHT PROHIBITS
DEFEAT DEVIATE FROM EXERCISING
CONTROL OVER THE ESSAY A AND
AUTHORIZES THE STATE TO DEVELOP
AND APPLY AND FORCE ADDITIONAL
REASONABLE CRITERIA WITHIN THE
STATE.
HOWEVER THE DV EIGHT CONTRACT
COMPEL SEE SAVE TO COMPLY WITH
THE VA POLICY ADVISORIES AND
GUIDANCE.
AND LIMITS THE ABILITY TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA VETERANS AND
OTHER TITLE THIRTY EIGHT
BENEFICIARIES.
AS AND MISTER MOVE HAS SAID OF
THAT -- PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED THE
SA AY'S CONDUCT COMPLIANCE
SURVEYS. FIFTY TWO STATE
APPROVING AGENCIES ONE IN EACH
STATE AND IN SOME STATES HAVE --
TO AND WE ALL DO BASICALLY THE
SAME THING HOWEVER -- WHAT WE'RE
CHECKING IS THE MONEY?
NOT THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION NOT
IF THEY ARE MEETING THE
STANDARDS OF THE LAW.
NOT IF THEY ARE OFFERING
ANYTHING REMOTELY CLOSE TO WHAT
THEIR ADVERTISING THE GOAL OF
THE V. A.'S CONTRACT IS TO
MONITOR AND MAINTAIN THE MONEY.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
THEY ARE PAYING TO THE STUDENT
AND TO THE VETERANS.
IS RIGHT CORRECTMEANING THERE
ARE NO OVER PAYMENT OR
UNDERPAYMENT THERE ARE SINCE
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THAT THAT.
COMPLAINTS SURVEY DOES.
NOTABLY SEE SAYS EFFORTS OF THE
LAST FEW YEARS TO HOLD SCHOOLS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ADVERTISING CLAIMS AND
ACCREDITING STANDARDS HAS DRAWN
NATIONAL ATTENTION.
C. SAVES ACTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT OF VARIOUS
VARIOUS NEWS AND REPORTS
ARTICLES LITIGATION HEARINGS AND
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES.
HOWEVER ABSENT SPECIFIC
CALIFORNIA LAW GOVERNING
OVERSIGHT OF VETERAN EDUCATION.
SEE SAY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
CHALLENGE WAS STRIKING THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN FOR FILLING
DEVIATES CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS.
AND MEETING CALIFORNIA'S
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
PROTECTION AND PRESERVATION OF
VETERAN IN THAILAND. TO QUALITY
EDUCATION AND THEIR GI BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- MEDINA AND
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS YES I I HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR EACH OF THE PANELS
AND STARTING WITH -- DOCTOR
MERION -- I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW
FREQUENTLY HOW REGULARLY THE
BUREAU OF PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION -- MEETS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE APPROVING
AGENCY FOR VETERANS EDUCATION.
RIGHT SO GREAT QUESTION I THINK.
I'VE BEEN THERE YEAR AND A HALF
OF THE AND A LITTLE BIT OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF.
AND I WANT TO SAY IT AGAIN I'VE
HAD I DON'T KNOW. FOUR FIVE
CONVERSELY OAK MEETINGS THREE OR
FOUR MEETINGS IN MULTIPLE
CONVERSATION.
IN THE YEAR AND A HALF YEAR TO
HAVE BEEN UNDER IS SORT OF YOU
BEEN CHEAP.
YEAH ALL RIGHT AND CONTINUED.
DR MARION DO YOU FEEL THAT THE
GIRL.
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION --
IS EXPLICITLY -- PART OF THEIR
MISSION IS VETERANS OUTREACH.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT'S NOT ONLY
VETERANS I THINK IS ALL STUDENTS
ABSOLUTELY BUT BUT INCLUDING
BETTER SURE NO QUESTION.
RIGHT AND HOW IS THE RE
ORGANIZATION -- IMPACTED I THINK
YOU ALLUDED TO IT -- YOU MENTION
OF THE RE ORGANIZATION OF THE
THE BUREAU -- HOW'S THAT
IMPACTED YOUR ABILITY TO CLOSE
THAT THESE LONG STANDING.
OPEN INVESTIGATIONS -- SO BRING
IT ON THE ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE
WHICH I TALKED ABOUT OVER THE
LAST FOUR MONTHS HE'S BEEN
POWERFUL IN NOT ONLY
RESTRUCTURING FOR ENFORCEMENT
UNIT BUT THE WHOLE BUREAU.
AND I THINK BEING ABLE TO BRING
PEOPLE IN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THAT AND DO THIS WORK
EVERY DAY AND HELPING US WITH
OUR PROCESS AND WE DEVELOPING A
MAKING A LITTLE BIT CLEANER AND
CLEARER.
I THINK IT'S BEEN SHOOT YOU CAN
SEE THE NUMBERS RIGHT SO WE WENT
FROM TWELVE HUNDRED OR A HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT IN DECEMBER AND NOW
WE'RE JUST ABOVE.
FIVE HUNDRED AND I THINK WITH US
BEING ABLE TO BRING IN NEW STAFF
THAT UNDERSTAND THIS WORK A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER THAN -- I
WOULD SAY THE AVERAGE IS BEEN
BENEFICIAL TO HELP INFORM OUR
STAFF AND ENGAGE THEM IN A WAY
THAT MAKES US DO I THINK BETTER
OUTREACH BUT ALSO BETTER
INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN IN THE ONES THAT YOU
WERE ABLE TO CLOSE DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW MANY OF THOSE --
CASES THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO
CLOSE -- INVOLVED VETERANS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER BUT I CAN GET BACK TO YOU
OKAY CRUCIATE THAT.
AND THEN I QUESTIONS -- TO
SECRETARY JOHNSON WHAT WHAT
WOULD YOU THINK WOULD BE AN
IDEAL WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION HOW
WOULD YOU DESCRIBE.
AN IDEAL.
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
CAN I ANSWER THAT SHE CAN JUST
COME BACK TO THE BUREAU.
SORRY FROM RECRUITING.
I I THINK THE BEST APPROACH
WOULD BE FOR US TO COLLABORATE
IN.
INSURING THAT WHATEVER THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR THE STATE
ARE BEING MET -- WHAT WE DO IT
WOULD SEE SAVE IS WE WHAT WE
WANT GRANT APPROVAL IF THE
SCHOOL DOESN'T DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE FIRST?
THAT'S IT AND SO THAT WILL TAKE
SOME WORKING WITH -- THE BPP
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR
RANTING AND INSTITUTION APPROVAL
FOR TITLE THIRTY EIGHT ACCESS TO
TURN TITLE THIRTY FUNDS.
THE PREREQUISITE IS THAT THEY
MUST BE APPROVED BY THE PIER FOR
TWO YEARS.
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN APPLY TO US.
SO -- BY THE TIME THE SCHOOL
GETS TO US.
THE HOPE IS THAT THEY'VE BEEN IN
OPERATION OFFERING THEIR
PROGRAMS OF EDUCATION AND DOING
THAT SUCCESSFULLY -- OUR
APPROACH IS.
IS DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF WITH THE
VA REQUIRES -- BUT WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S BEING LOOKED AT BEFORE
THE GRANT OF APPROVAL IS
ADMINISTERED THIS IS THE BEST
APPROACH.
THANK YOU AND WHAT IS YOUR
WORKING RELATIONSHIP.
LIKE WITH PUBLIC AND INDEPENDENT
NON NON PROFIT SCHOOLS.
WELL WE DON'T REALLY IT.
BUT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT -- EMPOWERS ONE OVER THE
OTHER -- WHAT WE DO IS WE DO
OUTREACH EFFORTS FOR EXAMPLE WE?
HAVE -- TRAINING SESSIONS THAT
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING SO THE
INSTITUTIONS CAN COME ASK
WHATEVER THE QUESTIONS ARE SO
THAT WE CAN.
ESTABLISH COMPLAINTS BEFORE THE
SUBMIT AN APPLICATION SO AND WE
DO THAT FOR ANY INSTITUTION
WHETHER IT'S PUBLIC PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT NONPROFIT ALL THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE INVITED. TO TO
BE INVOLVED IN THAT AND THEN
DOES THE LACK OF COORDINATING
ANTIQUE ENTITY MAKE YOUR JOB.
MORE DIFFICULT TO DO.
I THINK WHAT MAKES MY JOB THE
MOST DIFFICULT OR THIS BUT FOR
THE STAFF IS.
THE CONTRACT THE CONTRACT THAT
THAT IS -- BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE D. THE BETTER
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS.
LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN WHAT THEY
CONTRACTORS TO DO.
WITHOUT -- SPECIFIC STATE LAWS.
THAT -- SAY WHAT WE CAN AND OVER
WHAT THE STATE CALIFORNIA WANTS
US TO DO WE MUST IT HERE TOO
WHAT THEY REQUIRE US TO DO.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST HURDLE.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN --
THE CALIFORNIA STATE APPROVING
AGENCY FOR VETERANS EDUCATIONS
LEARNS THAT THERE IS A TROUBLING
INFORMATION ABOUT A SCHOOL.
IS THIS IS THIS INFORMATION
REPORTED TO ANYONE.
WHEN YOU MEAN IN ADVANCE TO US
[inaudible]
IF YOU [inaudible]
FIND OUT [inaudible]
ANYTHING.
CONCERNING CONCERNING ANY
DECISION YES OR FOR THE
INSTITUTION.
IS THAT INFORMATION SHARE.
IT IS SHARED AND WITH WHOM WITH
THE BUREAU -- RIGHT AND MY LAST
QUESTION -- WHAT OUR STUDENTS
VETERANS AND SERVICE MEMBERS?
FOR ME AT LEAST AS IT RELATES TO
CALVET AND SEE SAVE.
THEIR ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER PUT
THE LAW ON THE BOOKS AB TWENTY
NINETY NINE THAT'S WHAT CODIFIED
AND SEE SAVE IN LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT WHILE WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
TO HAVE SCHOOLS APPLY TO US WHEN
WE WERE IN LITIGATION WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT WE WERE APPLYING
FEDERAL LAW BECAUSE THERE AREN'T
ANY STATE LAWS.
SO WE LACK THE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
LEGISLATIVELY MEANING WE HAVE NO
LAWS TO DEFEND WHAT ACTIONS THAT
WE TAKE OTHER THAN THE FEDERAL
LAW.
SO THEN THAT'S WHEN THE VA GETS
TO COME IN AND SAY.
YOU'RE NOT DOING THAT WITH OUR
MONEY YOU'RE GOING TO DO
COMPLIANCE OR RACE CHECK THE
MONEY AUDIT THE STUDENTS.
WE THEY ARE NOT PAYING FOR THEIR
THIS IS HOW THEY COMMUNICATED TO
US IS THAT THEY'RE NOT PAYING
FOR THAT SERVICE AND SO WE HAVE
THE LAW.
BUT WE HAVE NO ENFORCEMENT OF
THE LAW BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
STATE LAW. TO ENFORCE WHAT IT IS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WANTS US
TO DO.
SO WERE CAUGHT.
IN A CATCH TWENTY TWO YES THE
WORK THAT WE DO WERE DESPERATELY
TRYING -- TO INSURE THAT WE LOOK
AT THINGS IN ADVANCE BUT THE
ENFORCEMENT OF IT NOW HAS BEEN
TAKEN AWAY FROM US THAT NEW
POLICY ADVISORY THAT CAME OUT.
FROM THE A AUGUST THIRTIETH
BASICALLY SAYS -- THEY DON'T
CARE.
IF THE SCHOOLS BET GOOD BETTER
INDIFFERENT WE ARE TO LISTEN TO
ANY OTHER STATE NOT JUST THE
BUREAU.
ANY STATE FEDERAL -- COUNTY CITY
APPROVING AGENCY OR ENTITY
INCLUDING ACCREDITATION THAT
MEANS THAT IF.
THAT INTO T. WHATEVER THE ENTITY
IS DOESN'T TAKE AN ACTION YOU
CANNOT WHICH MEANS VETERANS ARE
NOT BEING PROTECTED.
AT ALL.
THAT'S THE FOR THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
JUST COMING BACK TO IT I'M.
A COMMENT THAT YOU MADE SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU THINK THERE ARE
SOME SPECIFIC.
PIECES OF LEGISLATION AND SOME
STEPS THAT WE CAN TAKE WHICH
WOULD STRENGTHEN YOUR ABILITY.
TO HOLD THE SPOT ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE AND A SUPPORTER
VETERANS CAN YOU ELABORATE YES I
ALSO SEE SAID CURRENTLY HAS A A
A REGULATION PACKET.
THAT IS JUST BEEN INTRODUCED AN
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH SO IT'S
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS --
WHERE WE ESTABLISHED -- WHAT WE
HOPE WOULD BE SUPPORTED BY --
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA.
TO HELP US IN FORCE WHAT IT IS
YOU REALLY HAVE SEEN US DO OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE WE DIDN'T
DEVIATE FROM ANYTHING THAT WE
HAVE DONE BEFORE IT MEANS THAT.
IT WOULD HOLD SCHOOLS
ACCOUNTABLE IN ADVANCE IT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE INSTITUTION.
THE THE FIRST PART OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THE FRESHEST BILL
SAID THAT THEY MUST APPLY BUT
THAT'S ALL IT SAID IS THAT THEY
MUST APPLY TO ASK.
SO WE WENT UP BEYOND THAT TO SAY
BUT THESE ARE THE TH THE
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT NEED TO
BE DONE THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
THINGS THAT THEY HAVE TO REPORT
TO US NEEDING TIME LINES IN
THOSE CUT AT THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
THAT'S ALL THAT IN THERE SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO DO THESE
THINGS.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS IS THE
REASON THAT THE D. V. A.'S --
POLICIES AND PROCEDURE ARE IN
THE POLICY ADVISORIES -- TRUMP
STATE LAW IS BECAUSE THERE ISN'T
ANY STATE LAW. TO ENFORCE SO
THEY SAY YOU DO WHAT WE SAY
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE ANY STATE
LAW OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU FOR PUTTING OUT
FOR IT AND YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO YOU IS THAT WE
WILL TAKE A VERY CLOSE LOOK AT
THAT AND DO EVERYTHING THAT THEY
CAN TO MAKE THAT A REALITY AND I
DO HAVE -- A QUESTION AT DOCTOR
MARION I THINK YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT IS DEALT
WITH HE SAID FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE COMPLAINTS THE LAST
FOUR MONTHS.
WHICH WILL YOU SAID THAT'S HALF
OF WHERE IT WAS STILL SEEMS LIKE
AN AWFUL.
LOT ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW MY STAFF
AND I AND OUR TEAM HAD HAVE HAD
VERY CALM VERY IS CONVERSATIONS
WHEN I FIRST CAME INTO BUREAUS
AROUND.
TWELVE HUNDRED AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S SOMEBODY
OUT THERE THAT NEED SOME
ASSISTANCE AND WE WANT TO HELP
THEM IN THE BEST WAY THAT WE CAN
IN MAKING IT MORE PERSONAL
UNDERSTANDING LIKE IF IT WAS ONE
OF US OR ONE OF OUR FRIENDS OR
ONE OF OUR FAMILY.
MEMBERS AND OUR VETERANS AT A
SERVICE COUNTRY EVEN HERE IN
SOME OF THE STORIES THAT I'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY.
YOU KNOW OUR OFFICE AND WE WANT
TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
IMPACT WHAT YOU WRITE A REMEMBER
ALSO WHEN THE BUREAU CAME BACK
INTO EXISTENCE IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN IT WAS ALREADY A COMPLAINT
BACKLOG OF OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS.
AND SO THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO
CATCH UP WITH THE LAST NINE
YEARS AND SO LUCKILY WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS IN
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF THAT
HAVE BEEN TURNED INTO VERY
POSITIVE THINGS BUT I CAN'T
AGREE WITH YOU MORE FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETY NINE IS. TOO MANY ONE
IS TOO MANY TO BE QUITE HONEST.
RIGHT AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU AND
YOUR TEAM OR SIGNING HIM.
TIME AND TIME AND A LOT AND
ENERGY AND DEALING WITH THIS YOU
KNOW JUST TAKING A STEP BACK
AGAIN ARE THERE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO.
THAT WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ROOT CAUSES OF THOSE OF THOSE
ISSUES.
GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT AND FOR ME I WOULD
I'M OPEN TO ANY AND ALL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL ALLOW US.
TO INCREASE OUR BELIEVES DO OUR
JOB AT A HIGHER LEVEL AND HAVE
MORE CONSUMER PROTECTION SO ANY
BILLS THAT COME OUT IN REGARDS
TO THAT TO SUPPORT US AND DO OUR
JOB AT A HIGH LEVEL.
I'M I'M FOR ABSOLUTELY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THE
MANAGER.
SO YOU'D MENTIONED THAT YOU HAD
AND I CAN'T THINK IN THOSE AYE
AYE.
I AM SO PLEASED THAT YOU'RE IN
THIS POSITION AND AND THE
PASSION THAT YOU LAWSUIT IS.
AND I KNOW WHAT YOU NOW.
I I UNDERSTAND SO HELP ME HELP
ME OUT [inaudible]
BUT YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU HAD --
TEN INDIVIDUALS PROFESSIONALS
THAT OF OVERSEE.
ELEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS WAS A
HUNDRED AND TEN A SCHOOLS PER
INDIVIDUAL -- WE KNOW WE WILL
LOOK THROUGH A LOT OF STATE
AGENCIES THAT -- HAVE.
EARLY HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ON
THEIR STAFF.
IS THERE A NUMBER THAT WOULD
GIVE YOU A BETTER BALANCE -- OF
SUPPORT. TO BE ABLE TO TEN IT AS
YOU MENTIONED YOU HAD SO MANY
COMPLAINTS.
IS THERE A NUMBER OF OF FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES WOULD BE A BETTER
BALANCE TO BE ABLE TO DO YOUR
JOB MORE EFFECTIVELY.
WELL IT IT REALLY WOULD DEPEND I
I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE IT
REALLY JUST DEPENDS ON HOW MUCH
MORE SUPPORT WE GET WITH THE LAW
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW REMEMBER.
THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS THAT THE
THE FEDS PAY TO THE STATE COVERS
EVERYTHING THAT THOSE FOLKS DO.
ALL TWELVE OF THOSE PEOPLE THERE
AND THAT THAT WOULD MEAN I HAVE
NOTHING.
LEFT TO DO WHAT WE WOULD WANT
WHICH WOULD BE TO FOR OVERSIGHT
AND MONITORING OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS SO EVEN AT BEST WE
WOULD NEED WHAT WAS CALM WHAT WE
HAVE NOW -- BECAUSE I HAVE
NOTHING.
THE THE VA EVEN WHEN WE HAVE
THESE LEVELS I STILL HAVE THE
CHALLENGE OF DOING THE EXACT
SAME THING WITH THE STATE LAW
BEING IN EFFECT -- I'M GOING TO
BE BALLOTS IN TRYING TO BALANCE
BETWEEN OKAY HOW MUCH OF MY
STAFF TIME CAN BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS.
DOING WHAT THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES ARE -- AND THEN Vì
ã PAY FOR IT IT'S GOING TO BE
A CHALLENGE THAT'S WHERE WE'VE
BEEN THAT'S WHERE WE'VE BEEN
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND I
THINK THEY NEED TO COME TO THE
FOREFRONT BECAUSE WHAT I'M
SAYING IS.
YOUR WORKLOAD IS GOING TO
INCREASE YES WITH THE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT IS CORRECT
SO IT HAS TO BE IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT THE TO THE WITH
THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD THAT HAS
TO BE A FUNDING MECHANISM TO BE
ABLE.
TO ADJUST TO THAT THAT WORK LOOK.
THAT BEINGS AND OTHERS THINGS
BEING SAID IS YOU KNOW.
WHEN WE WORK ON THIS EARLIER ON
WE DID HAVE TO TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS DUE TO SOME SOME?
HIGH LEVEL PRESSURE TWENTY WHICH
DID WATER DOWN THE BILL TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT NOW AND GO BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL FORMAT -- JUST WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF BOTH OF YOU
ON WHAT IS NECESSARY TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL.
OF OF OF GOING FORWARD -- WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT?
YOU KNOW WHAT IS NEEDED OR WHAT
IS NECESSARY TO SUPPORT -- YOU
FOR YOU SAID YOU HAD. SEVEN
BILLS OUT THAT WERE OUT THIS
YEARS OR SO SO.
THEY WERE IN IN.
WE DO NOT KNOW THE IN THE LATE.
AS A WHOLE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A THERE'S A
CERTAIN -- ABILITY TO AMEND
BILLS.
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO
BOTH YOU AFTERWARDS TO BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW WITH THE CHAIRS TO
BE ABLE.
TO MAYBE MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO
POLICY COMMITTEES THAT WOULD
MAKE THIS.
A LAST TIME.
LET'S FIX THIS.
GO FOR PROTECT THE VETERANS
PROTECT.
ALL OF THE STUDENT'S GOING
FORWARD YOU KNOW THIS PROCESS
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS HOW WE GET
THIGS DONE WHEN YOU COME IN BE.
WHEN YOU'RE ABLE TO BE FRANK AND
ON ON FOURTH COMING TO US HOW WE
CAN BETTER SUPPORT YOU?
THIS IS HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK I'M REALLY JAZZ SO WE CAN
DO THIS TOGETHER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HAD A ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL.
SO A A FOLLOW ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRASIER'S.
HOW LONG IS THE AVERAGE TIME? TO
FINISH A COMPLAINT TO RESEARCH
AND ANALYZE IT IN AND COME OUT
WITH THE OUTCOME.
SURE THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY HARD
QUESTION BECAUSE DEPENDING ON
THE LEVEL OF THE COMPLAINT AND
DID THE COMPLAINT COME DIRECTLY
TO US OR DID HE COME FROM
ANOTHER BUREAU BOARD.
SO THAT'S A REALLY HARD QUESTION
TO PASS TO BE QUITE HONEST
ANSWERED BUT I WILL WORK ON
TRYING TO GET YOU AN ANSWER.
I'LL TAKE ANYTHING AGO I WORK ON
SO.
WHAT'S THE AVERAGE TIME TO
FINISH A COMPLAINT [inaudible]
IT'S A MAKE SOME UPDATES OKAY A
S. S. I WOULD HATE TO DO THAT
JUST BECAUSE WE TAKE THAT STILL
SERIOUS AND I WOULD RATHER GIVE
YOU A MORE SUCCINCT ANSWER TO BE
QUITE HONEST.
HONEST OKAY WE CAN DO THAT AFTER
THE HEARING HERE ABSOLUTELY YOU
CAN GIVE ME AN ESTIMATE ON I
MEAN IF YOU HAVE.
AROUND TWELVE HUNDRED COMPLAINTS
ANOTHER HAVE HAD [inaudible]
OKAY HEN -- I'M JUST CURIOUS
BECAUSE I WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
STAFF IN THEM PROVED.
IN ORDER TO HAVE MORE -- I IS ON
THE PROBLEM IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE.
THE COMPLAINTS ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
THAT JUST MAKES LOGICAL SENSE
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BEGINNING
TO KNOW.
HOW LONG IS THE AVERAGE COMPLAIN
AND THEN WE CAN SEE WHAT THE
IMPROVEMENT IS OR?
I FOUND IN THE CORPORATE WORLD
THAT WHEN YOU PUT MORE EYES ON A
PROBLEM SOMETIMES IT EXTENDS THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE NOW.
YOU'RE ANALYZING MORE DATA MORE
INFORMATION YOU FOUND MORE
PROBLEMS THAN WHAT YOU THOUGHT
YOU HAD.
SO YOU NEVER KNOW YES ABSOLUTELY
OKAY -- LAST QUESTION
[inaudible]
UNACCREDITED SCHOOLS.
AND I'M NOT HUNTING HERE OKAY
THIS IS A OF OF BASIC QUESTION
NUMBER.
EIGHTY SIX NOT LOOK AT IT
UNACCREDITED SCHOOLS NOT
NECESSARILY BAD OR GOOD -- I'M%
THINKING IN MY HEAD MY LITTLE
NOODLE.
THAT UNACCREDITED SCHOOLS COULD
VERY WELL BE NEW SCHOOLS NEW
EDUCATION CONCEPTS THAT JUST
HAVEN'T BEEN ACCEPTED YET OR
ACCREDITED WAR THEY JUST
HAPPENED -- MARKED OFF ALL THE
BOXES IS THAT A GOOD WAY FOR ME
TO THINK OF THAT WILL IT AN
ACCREDITED SCHOOL I MEAN IT'S BY
CHOICE.
TRANSPORTATION IS BY CHOICE
WHETHER SCHOOL DECIDES TO DO
THAT -- SO WHAT HAPPENS IS IS
THAT WHEN AN INSTITUTION APPLIES
TO US -- IF THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
ACCREDITATION.
RECOGNIZED AS ON A CREDIT IT.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE CHOSEN THAT
BECAUSE FINANCIALLY IT MAY NOT
MAKE SENSE TO THEM -- TYPICALLY
YOU WOULD FIND IT THE
UNACCREDITED INSTITUTIONS ARE
THOSE WHO SMALLER INSTITUTIONS
THAT SURVEY GENERAL POPULATE
BERRY SMALL POPULATION OR HAVE A
SPECIFIC -- CURRICULUM THAT
MEETS A PARTICULAR NICHE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLEAR FINE
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR OF DOE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL --
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES THAT -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
ACCUSE SEE SAVE A BEING
OVERZEALOUS ON APPLYING ANY OF
THE STANDARDS BASICALLY FOR
EXAMPLE -- THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY REQUIRES
THAT AN INSTITUTION HAVE A
PERFORMANCE FACT SHEET AND THAT
PERFORMANCE FACTUALLY
ESSENTIALLY SAYS TO A STUDENT --
THIS PROGRAM IS OFFERED HAS BEEN
OFFERED IN THIS IS THE SUCCESS.
OF THAT PROGRAM.
WELL WHAT WE DO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DO IT WITH MY
AGENCY IS I REQUIRE THAT MY
STAFF.
GET THE DETAILS.
THEY NEED TO IF YOU SAY BROWN
NUMBER FOR THE SAKE OF THIS
CONVERSATION THAT FIFTY PEOPLE
WENT THROUGH THE PROGRAM AND
TWENTY FIVE OF THEM THIRTY
WHATEVER.
THAT.
JOB WERE EMPLOYED IN THE FIELD.
THEN WE VALIDATE THAT WE
VALIDATE THE INFORMATION WOULD.
EITHER YOU'RE PRESENTING US WITH
ACTUAL DATA ARE YOU NOT.
THAT MEANS YOU SEND US FIFTY
NAMES.
WE LOOK THROUGH THOSE WE
RANDOMLY.
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THAT SOMEONE
ANYBODY EVERYBODY GOT A JOB.
IF THEY WE IF THEY COME BACK AND
THEY HAVEN'T RECEIVED EMPLOYMENT
THOSE THAT DATA ISN'T.
ACCURATE THEN WE DON'T APPROVE
THE PROGRAM.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT THE VA SAYS THAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO.
THEY DON'T WANT US GOING INTO
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL -- THERE
ARE EVEN INSTITUTIONS WHERE WE
SAY -- THEY SUBMIT THEIR
APPLICATION THEY WANT TO APPLY
FOR CREDIT PROGRAMS WILL.
WE REQUIRE THAT YOU ARE MEETING
YOUR REQUIREMENTS FOR
ACCREDITATION THE BENCHMARKS
THAT THE IT CREDITORS THAT.
IF YOU DON'T WE WON'T APPROVE
YOU.
Vì ã SAYS THAT'S TOO FAR.
THEIR CREDIT IT THEY SHOULD BE
APPROVED BY US.
SO IT HAS TO LITERALLY.
TAKEN OUT ALL OF THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE PUTTING
IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN.
THEY CAN OFFER THE PROGRAM IT
JUST WON'T BE FOR VETERANS UNTIL
THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
MEET THE STANDARD THEY NEED TO
COME UP AND BE ABLE TO INSURE
BECAUSE WHAT'S AT RISK IS NOT
JUST BENEFIT.
LIKE -- MISS RUTH WAS SENT ITS
ENTITLEMENT THEY ONLY HAVE A
CERTAIN WINDOW.
SO IF FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS THEIR
CREDITORS SAYS ALL YOU CAN KEEP
TEACHING THE PROGRAM YOU CAN
BRING IT UP TO WHATEVER THE
STANDARD IS THAT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
OF A BIT OF A VETERANS
ENTITLEMENT.
THAT HE OR SHE WILL NOT GET BACK
FROM THE VA.
SO WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO DO IT
ON THE BEGINNING AT THE
BEGINNING TO NOT GIVE YOU
APPROVAL BECAUSE IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT TO TAKE IT ONCE IT'S
BEEN ISSUED.
OKAY AND THEN ALSO IS SO IS IT
CORRECT TO SAY THAT IF THE
BUREAU HAS AN ACTIVE APPROVAL OF
THE PROGRAM TO A SCHOOL THAT SEE
SAID CAN'T SUSPEND THAT PROGRAM
IF IT FINDS VIOLATIONS THAT IS
CORRECT.
IF THE A CREDITOR FIND A
VIOLATION AND THEY REMAIN
ACCREDITED.
WE MUST KEEP THAT PROGRAM FOR
THAT AREN'T.
ALL WHILE THE VETERAN KNOWS
NOTHING.
OKAY WELL THIS HAS BEEN -- VERY
INFORMATIVE -- REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR SPENDING SOMETIME
WITH US THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
I WOULD LIKE NOW TO INVITE UP
OUR FINAL.
AND I AM PLEASED TO INVITE UP.
A MAJOR SANITARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
DEAN NANCY MATERNAL MONTGOMERY.
OF IRVINE VALLEY COLLEGE AND
SETH READ OF READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS
.
YOU MAYBE GET.
HEAR ME NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
TALK ABOUT MY PROGRAM AND THE
UNIQUE TOUCH POINTS THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE TRANSITIONING SERVICE
MEMBERS AND ALSO OUR VETERANS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M JAN AND TERRY I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE WORK FOR
WARRIORS JOB PLACEMENT PROGRAM.
OUR PLACEMENT PROGRAM IS IN ITS
SEVENTH YEAR OF EXISTENCE.
AND OUR CONSTITUENCY THAT WE
SERVE IS ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
MILITARY AND VETERANS
COMMUNITIES.
THIS INCLUDES HEN IS NOT LIMITED
TO THE RESERVES THE VETERANS ALL
FAMILY MEMBERS SPOUSES CHILDREN.
AND I GOES FAR TO SAY AUNTS AND
UNCLES.
D. AT RISK USE THAT ARE PART OF
OUR YOUTH CHALLENGE COMMUNITIES
AND ALSO RECENTLY -- DECLARED
EMERGENCY SURVIVORS FOR EXAMPLE
THE YOU CAN'T FIRE -- WITH
REGARD TO OUR UNIQUE POPULATION
THAT WE SERVE.
I THINK THAT I'M IN A GOOD
POSITION TO SPEAK.
ABOUT THE CURRENT NEEDS OF THE
SERVICE MEMBERS THAT WE TOUCH.
ON AVERAGE MOST OF MY CLIENTS
AND REPORTS OF A SIXTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PLACEMENTS RIGHT NOW.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
AND MOST OF MY CLIENTS HAVE USED
THE GI BILL OR USING THE GI BILL
IN SOME CAPACITY OR ANOTHER. ONE
OF THE BIGGEST ADVANTAGES THAT
WE SEE ABOUT HAVING THE GI BILL
BENEFITS.
IS.
YOUR ABILITY TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A CUSHIONING PERIOD
ALMOST.
SO THERE'S NOT A LOT OF THERE'S
NOT AS MUCH PRESSURE I WOULD SAY
ON AVERAGE FOR SOMEONE TO COME
OUT OF THE ACTIVE DUTY SAVE BY A
WAY OF TAPS ARE CAL TAPS. TO GO
IMMEDIATELY INTO THE FIRST JOB
THEY FIND BECAUSE THEY NEED THE
FINANCES SO SO QUICKLY.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS A
TENDENCY TO HOLD OFF TO PURSUE
THE EDUCATION OR IN SOME CASES
PURSUE THE VOCATIONAL TECHNICAL
SCHOOL THE APPRENTICESHIP --
WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY CHOOSE.
BUT THE THE BEST VALUE THAT I
SEE OF THE GI BILL IS THE
ABILITY TO BE FLEXIBLE WITH
THOSE DECISIONS.
AND THEN TO TAKE YOUR TIME AND
REALLY.
DECIDE WHAT YOU WANT TO DO AND
ALSO BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A RECORD
UNEMPLOYMENT ACROSS THE STATE.
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALMOST LIKE A
BUYER'S MARKET FOR JOBS.
WE HAVE ALL THESE TRANSITIONING
SERVICE MEMBERS OF THING
CALIFORNIA VETERANS COMMUNITIES
ARE FAMILIES AND EVERYONE.
AND WE'RE A REALLY NEAT PLACE
WHERE I'M NOT PUTTING THEM INTO
JOBS AND PUTTING THEM INTO
CAREERS.
PUTTING HIM INTO NEXT LEVEL
EMPLOYMENT AND WITHOUT HAVING
THE GI BILL BENEFITS.
I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY WOULD BE
AS COMPETITIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I NANCY
MONTGOMERY I AM A THE ASSISTANT
DEAN AT UC IRVINE VALLEY COLLEGE
I COME TO YOU TODAY WITH SOME
DATA AND SOME INFORMATION ABOUT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE POPULATION
OF VETERANS CURRENTLY WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITHIN THE STATE.
WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHTY TO NINETY
THOUSAND OF VETERANS THAT ARE
ENROLLED IN THE COLLEGE'S --
THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANY DATA
WE'VE NEVER GOTTEN ANY DATA ON
THE STUDENTS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE SET UP UNIFORM GUIDELINES
IN DATA KIND OF RESEARCH
PROJECTS OUT THERE RECENTLY THIS
LAST YEAR -- I WAS THE RECIPIENT
OF AN INNOVATION GRANT THROUGH
THE STATE WE DID A STATEWIDE
STUDY OUT OF A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES IT'S THE STATE OF THE
VETERAN STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS THE FIRST
DATA EVER.
ON POST NINE ELEVEN VETERANS
THAT ARE ENROLLED IN THE STATE --
pINFORMATION AND MOSTLY
INFORMATION THAT WE KIND OF
ALREADY KNEW BUT NOW IT'S
QUANTIFIABLE AND IN EVIDENCE
HERE.
WE SENT OUT -- WE RECEIVED ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SURVEYS FROM
VETERANS WE SURVEYED A HUNDRED
AND SIX COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
DID OBSERVATIONS WE DID FOCUS
GROUPS ALL OF IT IS DOCUMENTED
IN HERE BUT LET ME READ I WROTE
A LOT OF IT IN HERE WITH MY TEAM.
BUT I DID WANT TO READ TO YOU
WHAT WE WERE LOOKING AT AND SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT CAME OUT
OF HERE AND THEN I'LL HIGHLIGHT
THAT DATA.
MANY U. S. VETERAN SEPARATE FROM
THE MILITARY AND ENCOUNTER
DIFFICULTIES IN TRANSITIONING TO
CIVILIAN LIFE MILITARY
SEPARATION REPRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT SHIFTS AND PERSONAL
AND SOCIAL IDENTITY PURPOSE
CULTURE RELATIONSHIPS AND LIVING
SITUATIONS AND THE LIVES OF
VETERANS.
MANY SERVICE MEMBERS SEPARATE
FROM THE MILITARY ILL EQUIPPED
TO BEGIN THEIR CIVILIAN LIVES BY
NOT SECURING HOUSING AND OR
EMPLOYMENT SERVICE MEMBERS MAY
BE CONTENDING WITH PHYSICAL AND
OR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
THESE ISSUES MAY BE COMPOUNDED
BY VETERANS NEED TO ADJUST TO
THEIR SELF IDENTITY.
AND TRANSITION TO CIVILIAN
CULTURE ALONG WITH THAT COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS FACULTY STAFF.
AND NON VETERANS STUDENTS MAY
NOT BE AWARE OF THE IMPACT THAT
SERVED IN THE MILITARY CAN HAVE.
I BET THOSE SERVED IN THE
MILITARY CAN HAVE ON THE ABILITY
OF VETERANS STUDENTS TO COPE
WITH AND OVERCOME MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT I JUST MENTIONED.
SOME OF THE I IMPORTANT DATA
THAT I JUST WANTED TO BRIEFLY --
GO OVER WITH YOU A SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT OUR VETERANS LOOK LIKE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS THE AGE
RANGE IS ABOUT TWENTY ONE TO
FORTY GENERALLY STE TWENTY FOUR
TO TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE
NEEDLESS TO SAY BECAUSE THEY'VE
SERVED BY ANYWHERE FROM ONE TO
EIGHT YEARS IN THE MILITARY WHEN.
THEY COME OUT.
MOSTLY A MALE POPULATION WE HAVE
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF FEMALES IN
THERE BUT GENERALLY IT'S MALES
MOSTLY MARINES AND ARMY BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THAT THE LARGEST
GROUPS THEY'RE OUT THERE YOU
WON'T SAY THEY SEE THAT SAN
DIEGO THOUGH YOU'LL SEE A LOT OF
NAVY OUT THERE -- ACCORDING TO
OUR DAILY WE LOOK ON HERE THAT
61% HAVE SERVED IN COMBAT ZONE
OR DEPLOYED TO FLOAT -- AND 70%
SUFFERED ILLNESS OR INJURY FROM
SERVICE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE
NUMBERS AND YOU THINK ABOUT THE
ILLNESS OR INJURY MY BACKGROUND
IS IN NURSING IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN
I FELL IN LOVE WITH VETERANS
YEARS AGO AT MY LAST COLLEGES
REDUCE COLLEGE WHEN A MARINE
WALKED IN AND ASKED.
ME IF I WOULD HELP THEM SET UP A
VETERAN RESOURCE CENTER AND I
TOLD THEM I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT VETERANS.
HI I SET MYSELF OFF AND I DID
RESEARCH THAT WAS PROBABLY TO
FEET TALL AND I FIGURED IT OUT
WHAT THEY REALLY NEEDED WAS
SUPPORT SERVICES THEY NEEDED
SOMETHING TO HELP THEM ACCLIMATE
BACK AND WE NEEDED TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES BEFORE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY BE IN COLLEGE AND
REALLY.
DO WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE WASTING
THEIR BENEFITS THAT'S THE WHOLE
BOTTOM LINE RIGHT THERE.
SO SOME OF THE HEALTH CONCERNS
THAT I LOOKED AT AND THEN I
FOUND THE VA LOOKS AT A LOT OF
THEM THE THREE MOST FREQUENT
VISITED HEALTH CONCERNS ARE
MUSCULAR SKELETAL.
MIDDLE DISORDERS AND SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS OF UNKNOWN ORIGIN THEY
DON'T KNOW WHERE IT'S COMING
FROM THEIR HEARING LOSS IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS AND I
WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT IF
YOU'RE A COLLEGE SETTING I DON'T
CARE WHERE YOU ARE IF YOU HAVE
HEARING LOSS.
YOU REALLY HAVE A DEFICIT WHEN
YOU GO IN THERE -- THE PROBLEM
THAT I SEE WITH THE VA HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IS THERE IS A ONE
YEAR WAIT TO EVEN GET AN
APPOINTMENT WITH AN AUDIOLOGIST.
TO ASSESS THE HEARING NEED IT
COST TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO GET THE HEARING DEVICES IN
YEARS TO BE ABLE TO HEAR THEIR
AND I HAVE HAD SEVERAL VETERANS
GOING TO GET THOSE TYPE OF
DEVICES.
AND BE ABLE TO DO SO MUCH BETTER
IN THEIR CLASSROOM BUT GETTING
IN THERE IN ACCESSING THAT IS
REALLY DIFFICULT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT THEY COME IN
WITH THE VA ALSO MENTIONS THAT
THE TOP THREE ARE PTSD SYMPTOMS
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER?
DEPRESSIVE SYMPTOMS AND ALSO IN
RODDICK.
THE COLLEGE DATA COMES OUT AND
SAYS THAT THEY HAVE THE THE MOST
IMPORTANT IT -- MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ARE AND ZAIDI
[inaudible]
DEPRESSION PTSD SYMPTOMS AND
LONELINESS.
THEY ALSO SAY THAT THEY HAVE
DIFFICULTY SLEEPING DIFFICULTY
CONCENTRATING AND FEELING
DISTANCE FROM OTHERS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T ALWAYS KIND OF FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE PART OF THE GROUP
WHEN YOU COME IN WITH THE A
GROUP OF YOUNGER STUDENTS IN THE
COLLEGE SETTING THERE.
THEY HAVE DISTURBING MEMORIES
THEY HAVE THOUGHTS AND THEY HAVE
THINGS THAT THEY THINK ABOUT IN
THEIR MILITARY COMBAT EXPERIENCE
ESPECIALLY THE MORE OFTEN THAT
THEY WERE DEPLOYED.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE A LOT MORE
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND ALSO
MEDICAL ISSUES THERE.
MILITARY SEXUAL ASSAULT
ACCORDING TO USA TODAY -- THE
OTHER DAY WOULD JUST TO STATED
THAT WE ARE UP SINCE 20001638%
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A
MILITARY SEXUAL ASSAULTS THOSE
ISSUES COME BACK TO US IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THOSE ISSUES ON HOW DO WE
CARE FOR THOSE.
THOSE MILITARY COMING BACK WHAT
DO WE DO.
IT'S WELL KNOWN IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT FEMALES DON'T
REALLY COME INTO A LOT OF OUR
VETERAN RESOURCE CENTERS THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY'RE A PART
OF IT SOMETIMES THEY FEEL
DISTANCE THEY DON'T LIKE THE
LANGUAGE THEY DON'T LIKE THAT
KIND OF A BARRACKS TYPE
SITUATION -- IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO EVEN REACH THOSE FEMALES IS
DIFFICULT TO REACH A LOT OF
MILITARY THAT ARE ON CAMPUS IS
THERE.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO IMPROVE THESE
TYPE OF THINGS WHAT CAN WE LOOK
AT WHEN WE'RE WE'RE?
LOOKING AT VETERANS IN COLLEGE
SYSTEMS THE IDEA IS TO KEEP THEM
THEIR PERSISTENCE AND THEIR
COMPLETION RATES CONSISTENT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY GRADUATE
TAKING ON I KNOW -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOCAL MENTIONED ABOUT THE
CONTINUING ON WITH TWELVE UNITS
THEY HAVE TO TAKE TWELVE UNITS
MINIMUM JUST TO GET THEIR VA
BENEFITS MOST OF THEM TAKE
FIFTEEN IN EIGHTEEN UNITS IN A
LOT OF TIMES ARE WORKING PART
TIME JOBS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THINGS
ORANGE COUNTY GIVES A A BASE PAY
OF LIKE TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR BOARD
HOUSING SAN FRANCISCO IS UP TO
ABOUT FORTY THREE TO FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH BECAUSE
OF THE COST OF LIVING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT BY THE
TIME YOU PAY RENT YOU PAY YOUR
BASIC COST OF LIVING THAT'S ONLY
REALLY FOR NINE MONTHS BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO STOP PAY PERIODS
DURING THE SUMMER THEY DON'T GET
PAID OR THEY GET HALF PAY?
AND THEN DURING THE WINTER WHEN
THEY HAVE ANY TYPE OF BREAK THEY
DON'T GET FULL PAY THAT MUCH.
SO YOU HAVE TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT
IN THERE TOO WHICH CAUSES STRESS
TO THEM.
THEY COME OUT WITH FOOD AND
SECURITY IS VERY LITTLE SUPPORT
A LOT OF TIMES MOST OF THEM WENT
INTO THE MILITARY BECAUSE THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR EIGHT A FAMILY
A UNIT THEY FOUND THAT IN THERE.
NOW THEY COME BACK OUT
ESPECIALLY FEMALES AND THEY HAVE
NO ONE TO COME OUT TO AND IT
REALLY MAKES A STRESSFUL YOU'LL
FIND THAT ON CALIFORNIA IS THE
LARGEST STATE WITH THE MOST
VETERANS BECAUSE EVEN WHEN
THEY'RE COMING FROM THE MIDWEST
OR ON THE EAST COAST.
ON A STAIN CALIFORNIA THEY LIKE
CALIFORNIA WHAT FOR WHATEVER
REASON I'M SURE IS THE WEATHER
IN THAT GIRLS AND WHATEVER ELSE
BUT BUT THEY DO STAY AND THEY
ENJOY THAT SO SO THAT'S A GOOD
PART OF IT -- BUT THEY ARE IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE
ARE THEIR FIRST AVENUE OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE'RE EASY
ACCESS SO MAKES IT REALLY NICE
THERE.
WHAT WE'VE DONE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS AS WE HAD FUNDING
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FUNDING THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
IRWIN FOR TAKING THAT CHARGE ON
THERE?
WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT FUNDING
GOING ON THERE TO SUPPORT SOME
OF OUR VETERAN RESOURCE CENTERS
WE NEED MORE SUPPORT MANY
DEDICATED STAFF WE NEED ACTED
COUNSELORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THEY COME IN A PUT THEIR
ACADEMIC PLANS TO GATHER THOSE
TWELVE UNITS REALLY COUNT. TO
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
TAKING FOR THAT MAJOR THE BE A
REQUIRES THAT YOU TAKE SPECIFIC
MAJORS AND IN THAT WAS MAJORS
YOU CAN ONLY TAKE SPECIFIC
CLASSES SO YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO TAKE BASKET WEAVING IN
CERAMICS AND GET THAT APPROVED.
THEY ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE MILITARY CREDITS ARE GIVEN
WE HAVE SUCH A DIVERSE -- RIGHT
NOW.
ACCUMULATION OF MILITARY CREDIT
SOME COLLEGES WILL GIVE FOUR
UNITS OTHERS WILL GIVE FORTY
UNITS I STRONGLY FEEL GIVING
FORTY UNITS TO A A VETERAN
THERE'S JUST COMING OUT OF THE
MILITARY THAT'S TRYING TO GET
THEIR LIFE TOGETHER IN
ACCLIMATING AND ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT I JUST STATED HERE.
NOT A WISE IDEA BECAUSE WE'RE
KIND OF SETTING THEM UP FOR
FAILURE WE NEED TO HELP THEM
ACCLIMATING GET THEMSELVES GOING
THERE.
TO SO AGAIN FUNDING THOSE
VETERAN RESOURCE CENTERS WHICH
ARE THE MAIN SOURCE OF THEIR
SUPPORT -- IN IN THAT MANDATING
POLICY PROCEDURES AND GUIDELINES
SO THAT WE HAVE THOSE SUPPORTS
ON THE VA HAS BEEN A VERY VERY --
DEVASTATING TYPE OF PROGRAM TO
WORK WITH FOR ANYBODY COMING OUT
ONLY 60% OF OUR VETERANS ARE
ACTUALLY ENROLLED IN BE A HEALTH
CARE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY NEED
TO BE ENROLLED IN AUTOMATICALLY
BEFORE THEIR DISCHARGED OFF A
BASE.
I TO CONTINUE THEIR PHYSICAL
THERAPY TO CONTINUE ANYTHING FOR
BACK SHOULDERS KNEES INJURIES
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THAT GOES ON
ESPECIALLY HEARING.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY OF THAT
ACCESS THERE SO THEY COME ONTO
OUR CAN'T COLLEGE CAMPUSES
NEEDLESS TO SAY IT'S A
POPULATION THAT DOESN'T.
ASK FOR MUCH THE KIND OF LIVE IN
SILENCE THE PROBLEM IS THOUGH
THAT LIVING IN THAT SILENCE IS
THEY SUFFER WITH THEIR OWN
INSIDE BONES AND THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO COMPLETE CLASSES THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO USE THEIR BENEFITS
LIKE THEY SHOULD AND THEY HUESO
THIRTY SIX MONTHS.
AND WE NEED TO GET HIM THERE --
I STRONGLY FEEL THAT AS I SAID
SUPPLYING THE SUPPORT SYSTEMS
AND GIVING THAT TO THE COLLEGES
WOULD MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
THIS BOOKLET YOU'LL FIND THAT WE
HAD -- FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SOME OF THE
KEY FINDINGS WAR NUMBER ONE WAS
ON HAT ON MET MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS WE NEED TO HAVE A A
COMPLETE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE VA
BRINGING MENTAL HELP FOR
PROVIDERS TO EVERY COLLEGE
CAMPUS THAT SHOULD BE MANDATED
THERE'S NO. TWO WAYS ABOUT IT
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN GENERAL ONE
IN THREE HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER.
THE POINT IS EVERYBODY NEEDS IT
BUT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT COMBAT
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT MENTAL
STRESS WERE LOOKING AT THE
ATROCITIES THAT OUR MILITARY
HAVE VIEWED AND VISUALIZED AND
BEEN A PART OF THEY NEED A LOT
MORE MENTAL HEALTH.
NUMBER TWO IS ALSO A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF VETERANS
STUDENTS UNIQUE CHALLENGES AMONG
THE V. R. C. STAFF AND FACULTY
FACULTY ARE SOMETIMES NOT ALWAYS
AND WE LOVE OUR FACTLY BUT
SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS
UNDERSTANDING WHEN VETERANS NEED
APPOINTMENTS ARE THEY HAVE
APPOINTMENTS MADE THERE.
YOU CAN CANCEL OF THE A
APPOINTMENT BECAUSE YOU WON'T
GET IT AGAIN FOR ANOTHER SIX TO
NINE MONTHS.
NEED FOR STUDENT FRIENDLY
BUSINESS HOURS AND SPACES NEED
FOR INCREASED CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT VETERANS STUDENTS
EDUCATIONAL PLANNING AND
BENEFITS THAT MEANS MORE
ACADEMIC COUNSELORS THAT ARE
TRAINED IN THEIR VA BENEFITS.
NEED FOR STRONGER PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN THE V. A AND THE R. C.'S
EVEN AND ROLLING THEM IN THE BE
A HEALTHCARE.
LACK OF CONSISTENT AND RELIABLE
DATA ABOUT VETERANS STUDENTS
AGAIN THIS IS THE FIRST DAY THAT
WE'VE EVER PRODUCED ON VETERAN
STUDENTS SO THOSE ARE THE ISSUES
WERE LOOKING AT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE STRONGLY SUGGEST AS A TEAM OF
US TO PUT TOGETHER AND AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET OUR
VETERANS. TO A TO GRADUATE
SOONER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO ONE TO
THE LAST.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET.
THREE WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS I REPRESENT THE
AMERICAN GI FORUM AMERICAN
LEGION.
AMVETS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL.
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA.
I SPENT FIVE YEARS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARMY AS AN INFANTRYMAN I
DEPLOYED BOTH IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN AND AFGHANISTAN AND
SPENT TWENTY TWO MONTHS DEPLOYED.
AFTER MY DISCHARGE FROM THE ARMY
I REALIZED THAT AS AN
INFANTRYMAN.
I DID NOT HAVE MUCH IN THE WAY
OF TRANSFERABLE SKILLS FROM THE
MILITARY.
THAT WOULD HELP ME INTEGRATE
INTO THE WORK FORCE.
I FACED SOME OF THE SAME
CHALLENGES AS MANY OTHER SERVICE
MEMBERS ON SEPARATING FROM THE
MILITARY.
WHERE TO WORK WHERE TO LIVE?
RENTING OR PURCHASING A HOME
GETTING KIDS TO DAYCARE AND OR
SCHOOL.
I WAS MOST CONCERNED.
WITH PROVIDING FOR MY FAMILY I
WAS ABLE TO GET A JOB AS A SHEET
METAL APPRENTICE MAKING MINIMUM
WAGE.
BECAUSE THE HIGH COST OF LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA.
I OFTEN HAD TO RELY ON FAMILY
AND FRIENDS TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
MY HEAD.
MOVING FROM APARTMENT TO
APARTMENT WAS A STRUGGLE FOR THE
FIRST FEW YEARS AFTER MY SERVICE.
I BECAME USED TO LIVING OUT OF A
DUFFEL BAG.
AFTER MY TWO TOURS.
BUT I COULDN'T BEAR MY FAMILY
LIVING THAT WAY AS WELL.
EVENTUALLY I LOOKED INTO
ATTENDING A FOR PROFIT TRADE
SCHOOL TO ADVANCE MY CAREER.
I HAD MY OWN USED TO GI BILL
BENEFITS AND I KNEW I HAD TO USE
THEM WITHIN FIFTEEN YEARS OF
MILITARY DISCHARGE.
DURING MY SEARCH FOR TRADE
SCHOOL I FOUND THAT I COULD NOT
EVEN GET INFORMATION.
FROM THE SCHOOL WITHOUT GIVING
THEM MY CONTACT INFORMATION.
THIS RESULTED.
IN [inaudible]
RELENTLESS.
CALLS.
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
EVEN FROM SCHOOLS THAT I
ATTENDED COMPLETED AND GRADUATED
FROM.
I SPENT NINE MONTHS IN ABOUT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
MY GI BILL BENEFIT.
A FOR PROFIT COLLEGE OBTAIN ALL
EPA REQUIRED CERTIFICATES TO
BECOME A SERVICE TECHNICIAN.
BUT IN POINT OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THAT FIELD.
WERE ALMOST NONEXISTENT.
I'VE SINCE SEEN OTHER SIMILAR
PROGRAMS AND I SEE NOW.
THAT'S THE ONE I WENT THROUGH
WAS SUB STANDARD.
I HAVE A CLOSE FRIEND THAT.
THAT I SERVED WITH ALL FIVE
YEARS OF MY SERVICE.
HE'S CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH A
SIMILAR PROGRAM HERE IN THIS
AREA.
SIMPLY BECAUSE HE NEEDS THE
ADDITIONAL INCOME FROM THE GI
BILL AS HE WORKS FULL TIME.
BUT HE IS NOT SATISFIED WITH THE
EDUCATION THAT HE IS RECEIVING.
LATER I ATTENDED YET ANOTHER
[inaudible] FOR PROFIT.
LATER ATTENDED YET ANOTHER FOR
PROFIT CERTIFICATION SCHOOL IN
SEARCH OF A TRADE THAT WOULD
LEAD TO A RELIABLE EMPLOYMENT.
AGAIN OPPORTUNITIES WERE FEW.
MAKING SURE THAT THE SCHOOLS ARE
HERE TO STANDARDS IS VITAL.
IS A VITAL PART OF PROTECTING
THE GI BILL FOR VETERANS LIKE ME.
WHY THE GI BILL SUCH IMPORTANT
BENEFIT?
FIRST IT ALLOWS VETERANS LIKE ME.
TO THAT LIST RIGHT AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL TO COME HOME TO PURSUE A
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
PROVIDES YOU WITH SOME INCOME
WHICH HELPS WITH THE
COMPLICATIONS OF WORKING WHILE
ATTENDING SCHOOL.
AS IT TURNS OUT I HAD TO WORK
FULL TIME IN ADDITION TO
ATTENDING SCHOOL FULL TIME.
THE GI BILL.
CAN CHANGE VETERANS LIFE
EDUCATION IS EMPOWERMENT.
WASTE IN THIS BETTER BENEFIT IS
A TRAGEDY.
AFTER A MORE PROGRAMS TO
TRANSITION VETERAN STRAIGHT INTO
THE WORK FORCE WHAT THE NEW
FOREVER GI BILL VETERANS WOULD
BE ABLE TO SAVE THEIR COLLEGE
BENEFIT OR PASS THEM ON TO THEIR
CHILDREN.
THIS WOULD INCREASE THE ECONOMIC
OUTPUT FOR VETERANS. FOR OUR
VETERANS AND THE BENEFIT
[inaudible]
OF AND IT BENEFITS THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS UNEMPLOYMENT
AND STUDENT AT IN CONCLUSION OUR
CLIENTS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
STRESS THE NEED. TO PROTECT THE
VIABILITY OF THE GI BILL
BENEFITS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
COLLEGES ARE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE VETERANS THAT
DESERVE THIS BENEFIT.
MANY ON VETERANS RETURN HOME AND
ARE CONFUSED ON WHAT COURSE THEY
SHOULD PERFECT.
PURSUE.
IN THEIR POST MILITARY LIFE.
UNSCRUPULOUS MARKETING TACTICS
AND SUB STANDARD CURRICULUM.
CHEATS THE VETERANS ARE THE
BENEFITS THEY'VE EARNED BY
VIRTUE OF THEIR SERVICE.
THE BILL WHOSE CALIFORNIA TO
ENCOURAGE THE PROPER USE OF THE
GI BILL BENEFITS.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND FEDERAL MONIES
COMING TO THE STATE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF TRAINING OUR VETERANS
TO FULLY PARTICIPATE IN SOCIETY.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME LEVEL
OVERSIGHT.
OVER FOR PROFIT TRADE SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE PROVIDING THE ACTUAL.
PRODUCT THEY THAT THEIR
ADVERTISING WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC TO
CALIFORNIA VETERANS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UP THE STREET THANK YOU FOR
SHARING.
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES I
THINK THAT REALLY HITS HOME AS
TO WHY WE HAVE TO LOOK MORE
CLOSELY AT THIS PROBLEM DO YOU
STILL HAVE STUDENT LOANS.
GOOD FOR YOU AFTER.
GOING THROUGH ALL THAT.
OF I GUESS THIS IS OF HER MS
MONTGOMERY -- IT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE TALKING A
LOT ABOUT HOW DO WE SEE WHAT THE
EFFECTIVENESS IS OF A EDUCATION
DO YOU THINK IT'S A DIFFICULT TO
EVALUATE CLAIMS ABOUT A SCHOOL --
WITH THAT THE SCHOOL PROGRAMS
LIABILITY IN THE MARKET.
YES I THINK IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF STUDENTS COME
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ASKED
AFTER THEY'VE WASTED A LOT OF
BENEFITS IF NOT ALL OF THEIR
BENEFITS AT A FOR PROFIT.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
IT'S ALSO VERY DIFFICULT ON THE
VETERAN AS HE SO WELL STATED IS
THAT -- WHEN THEY COME IN THEY
THEY ALSO FACE ANOTHER KIND OF --
FEELING OF DISGRUNTLED AND ALSO
FEELING OF I GOTTA START THIS
ALL OVER AGAIN IT'S A VERY
DISHEARTENING TO SEE A VETERAN
COME IN AFTER THEY'VE TRIED SO
HARD.
AND THEY'VE LOST A MAJORITY OF
THEIR BENEFITS AS OR THEY HAVE
GONE FINANCIAL AID OR TAKE OUT
LOANS TO TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION AND THEY TRIED TO DO
THAT AND WE'VE HAD SEVERAL OF
THEM DO THAT AT MY LAST COLLEGES
REDUCE AND IT COMING TO IRVINE.
BUT AND WHAT ABOUT THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE -- EITHER GRADUATING
FROM THE AND TWO YEARS OF
COLLEGE AND THEN GOING ON TO A
FOUR YEAR PROGRAM YOU FOLLOWING
ANY OF THEM SEE WHAT THEY'RE AND
AND HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH THAT.
IS THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
SET GUIDELINE A STANDARD OF
PRACTICE SO TO SPEAK IN ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BE VETERAN
RESOURCE CENTERS ONLY A FEW OF
US MAYBE A HANDFUL OUT OF THAT
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN ACTUALLY
ARE ABLE TO FOLLOW THEIR
STUDENTS FIND OUT WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO LOOK.
AT THEIR COMPLETION THEIR
PERSISTENCE RATES FIND OUT WHO'S
DROPPING OUT WHO TO DO THE
RESEARCH ON WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
COORDINATORS THEY DON'T HAVE
STAFF AND THEIR MAYBE THEIR
ACADEMIC COUNSELORS 25% OF THE
TIME.
OUR COLLEGE DOES FOLLOW THAT WE
HAVE TO ACTUALLY THEY'RE JUST
INTERVIEWED AT YALE WE HAD ONE
THAT WENT TO STANFORD LAST YEAR
WHICH IS HIGHLY HARD TO GET INTO
WHEN YOU'RE TRANSFERRING IN AND
FOUR YEAR LIKE THAT. ONE IS
GOING AGAIN TO STAND FOR THIS
YEAR THEY GO TO UNIVERSITY
KENTUCKY WE HAD WE FOLLOW ALL OF
THEM DOWN THE LINE WE FIND OUT
WHERE THEY'RE GOING BECAUSE
NEEDLESS TO SAY OUR ACADEMIC
COUNSELOR RIGHTS THEIR LETTERS
OF RECOMMENDATION AND THEN WE
ARE ABLE TO FIND OUT WE HAVE.
THIRTY TWO GRADUATING RIGHT
TODAY WE'RE HAVING A GRADUATION
PARTY WITH TALK OF MAN AT OUR
COLLEGE -- AND SO THEY ARE.
WE HAVE THE LIST OF THOSE NAMES
AND WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THAT OTHER COLLEGES ARE
NOT ABLE TO DO THAT BUT THAT
SHOULD BE A STANDARD OF PRACTICE.
SO -- I'M I'M WE KNOW IRVINE
VALLEY IS A MODEL IF YOU LOOK AT
THE OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CALIFORNIA DO YOU THINK THAT
THEY ARE OFFERING ENOUGH
PROGRAMS OR CLASSES TO HELP
VETERANS SIDE TRANSITION.
SOME WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT I
THINK THE PROBLEM THERE IS THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SUPPORT
SERVICES NOW SO TRANSITIONING NO.
BUT THE COURSES HAVE TO BE THEY
ALMOST NEED A CAREER ASSESSMENT
BEFORE THEY LEAVE BASE TO FIND
OUT WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
MY CONCERN IS THAT I HAVE.
AN ELECTRICAL STE -- STUDENT
COMES IN WITH A VAST AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICAL EXPERIENCE THAT HE
WAS TRAINED IN THE MARINE CORPS
THERE HE COMES OUT NEEDS I HE'S
WALKING OUT OF THE CENTER WITH
ME AT MY LAST COLLEGE AND I SAID
SO HOW ARE YOUR CLASSES DOING HE
SAYS TO ME.
WELL I'M FEELING EVERY CLASS I
SAID WHOA LET'S STOP I SEE WHAT
YOU MEAN YOU'RE FEELING EVERY
CLASS HE SAYS YEAH I DON'T WANT
TO BE HERE I WANT TO BE AN
ELECTOR XIN NOBODY EVER ASKED ME.
SO WHAT I WALKED HIM BACK IN AND
I SAID FIND AN ELECTRICAL
COLLEGE FOR HIM TO GO TO NOW HE
ENDED UP TRANSFERRING TO PALOMAR
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THAT TYPE OF
PROGRAM THERE.
SO EVERY COLLEGE IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE OF THE TYPE OF PROGRAMS
THAT THEY OFFER SOME OFFER
NURSING PROGRAMS WE HAVE SO MANY
MEDICS AND CORPSMAN COMING OUT --
WITH MILITARY CREDITS THAT THEY
SHOULD BE GIVEN FOR WHAT THEY'VE
LEARNED ALSO IN THE MILITARY TO
AND THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER TOPIC
THERE BUT BUT I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAREER ASSESS
FIND OUT WHERE THEY'RE GOING IF
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
HELP THEM FIGURE.
THAT OUT AND KIND OF WITH SOME
TYPE OF TESTING OR SOME TYPE OF
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS THAT THEY CAN
TAKEN FIGURED OUT WITHIN THE
FIRST SEMESTER.
YEAH WE NEED A FEW MORE OF YOU.
TO YEAH THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL SO
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE BIGGEST --
CHALLENGES THAT VETERANS FACE
ENTERING THE CIVILIAN JOB MARKET.
AND WHAT ALLEN DO YOU -- PREPARE
THEM FOR THAT AS THROUGH THE
PROGRAM THAT -- YOUR COLLEGE
THEY NEED SOME TYPE OF
INTERNSHIP.
I THINK OUR WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
MONEY SHOULD BE UTILIZED A LOT
MORE EFFICIENTLY WITH VETERANS I
BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES TO INTERNET
DIFFERENT BIG COMPANIES THAT.
AT EVENTHERE'S IN IRVINE
THERE'S TACO BELL THERE'S
EIGHTEEN T. ALL OF THEIR YOU
KNOW THEIR BIG SATELLITE
COMPANIES THERE THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO IN TURN IN THERE AND
FIND OUT WHAT THEY REALLY WANT
TO DO SEE IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANTED.
TO FIND OUT GO TO SOME OF THE
ELECTRICAL UNIONS THE PLUMBING
PIPE BANNERS AND AND GET SOME
TYPE OF IF I HAVE OF THAT FROM
COMING OUT THAT HAS BEEN. FOUR
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN ELECTRICAL
IN THE MARINES I SHOULD HAVE BE
ABLE TO JUST PUT HIM RIGHT INTO
THE ELECTRICAL UNION RIGHT THERE
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND SAY YOU
SHOULD BE WIPED OUT WITH IT'S A
FIVE YEAR PROGRAM WIPED OUT WITH
ONE AND A HALF TO YEARS.
OF CREDIT NEEDLESS TO SAY THEY
HAVE TAP COMPETENCY EXAMS TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE WHERE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE AND THEN THEY GO
RIGHT ON THROUGH AND FIGURE OUT
THAT THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
SO I THINK MORE OPPORTUNITY BUT
WE NEED TO INVEST A LOT MORE
TIME IN FIGURING OUT WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY BRING THEM FROM THE
MILITARY BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO
MANY JOBS IN THE MILITARY LET'S
FIGURE OUT WHICH ONE THEY LIKED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TERM.
YES -- MY FIRST QUESTION -- SEC.
DO YOU FEEL THAT YOU GOT
ANYTHING OF OF PARTICULAR VALUE.
THAT WAS HELPFUL TO YOU -- LIKE.
USING YOUR GI BILL.
I BELIEVE -- ALL EXPERIENCES
THROUGH LIFE FOR VALUABLE -- I
DO NOT FEEL LIKE.
THE EDUCATION THAT I RECEIVED
PROVIDED ME -- ANY BENEFIT TO MY
FUTURE I WAS ABLE TO OBTAIN A
JOB.
WITH -- I I DID NOT NEED THAT
EDUCATION TO ATTAIN THE JOB THAT
I DID I COULD CAME IN OFF THE
STREET.
AND THEY WERE TO TRAIN ME -- THE
SAME WAY THAT I WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN.
GOING TO THAT SCHOOL.
WELL I I JUST WANNA SAY
PERSONALLY THAT I I I FIND IN
THE I THINK THE MAJOR THERE WAS
HERE AT THE BEGINNING -- YOU
KNOW IN THE TEST OF TESTIMONY
THAT WE'VE HAD FROM YOU AND AND
A COUPLE WEEKS BACK WHEN WE
HEARD THE BILLS -- IS JUST SUCH
A TRAGEDY NO NGUYEN AND TO
REITERATE AGAIN THE WHEN WE ASK
MEN AND WOMEN -- YOUNG PEOPLE.
IN THIS COUNTRY TO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE -- TO SERVE
THEIR COUNTRY AND THEN COME BACK.
AND HAVE -- THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
KIND OF STOLE STATE STOLEN FROM
THEM.
IS SUCH A A TRAGEDY AND I HOPE
THAT THE WORK ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE WORK.
OF WITH MR VOEPEL AND MR FRAZIER
THAT WE CAN.
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE KIND
OF THINGS DON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND MY APOLOGIES THAT THAT
HAPPENED TO YOU MY PERSONAL
APOLOGIES -- TO A MAJOR TERRY.
IS THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT
WORKING TO GET THE WORD OUT
ABOUT THE NEW -- MILITARY GI
BILL.
YES SIR IT IS AND AS A PERSON
YOU CAN ACCESS THAT JUST WANTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK YOU.
FOR MAKING IT SO MORE WIDELY
AVAILABLE TO BE UTILIZED.
BY A OUR NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS
AND OUR STATE MILITIA.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MIGHT
NOT UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE.
THE REGULAR MILITARY ACTIVE DUTY
IS TITLE TEN TITLE.
TEN IS A REQUIREMENT TO ACCESS
THE FEDERAL GI BILL.
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD YOU HAVE
TO GO ON MULTIPLE DEPLOYMENTS IN
ORDER TO ACCESS THE FULL BENEFIT.
OF THE FEDERAL GI BILL.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION OF TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY PRETTY
CONSTRAINED.
AND AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
OF LAST YEAR.
LOOSEN THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND
MADE IT.
MUCH MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR MEMBERS
OF OUR FORCE.
PRIMARILY PEOPLE WHO RESPOND TO
STATE EMERGENCIES LIKE THE
CAMPFIRE. TO ACCESS THE BENEFITS
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER DEPLOYED
SERVICE MEMBER WOULD.
SO YES HANNAH IN SHORT I WOULD
SAY THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ADVERTISE THAT.
THANK YOU.
AND MY LAST QUESTION IS -- TO
DEAN MONTGOMERY AND I I WANT TO
SAY THIS THAT IF FIVE WAS A
RETURNING -- VETERANS -- LOOKING
TO USE MY GI BILL I'D WANT TO BE
IT IRVINE VALLEY.
AND AND I THINK I WOULD GET MY
MONEY'S WORTH THEIR SO -- MY
QUESTION. TO YOU DEMON JR MARIE.
DO YOU FIND THAT THE AIR FORCE
THE AIR FORCE -- THEY OFFER A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSCRIPT IS
IS THAT CORRECT YEAH.
AND IS THAT -- IS THAT HELPFUL --
AT AT YOUR INSTITUTION -- THAT
IS RIGHT RIGHT IF THE OTHER
BRANCHES OF THE MILITARY.
THEY DON'T OFFER THE SAME THING
AND IF THEY DID WOULD THAT BE
HELPFUL I THINK ALL OF THE
TRANSCRIPTS ARE DIFFICULT TO
DECIPHER.
AND WHAT HAPPENS IS MY COLLEGE
CAN OFFER A THREE UNIT ENGLISH
COURSE WHICH CAN BE DIFFERENT
THEN MY SISTER COLLEGE YOU CAN
ALSO BE DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER
COLLEGE IN THE SYSTEM.
THERE FOR THE SAME THING HAPPENS
WHEN YOU GET THOSE JOINT SERVICE
TRANSCRIPT.
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT SO THEY
MAY ONLY GIVE TWO UNITS WE
REQUIRE THREE UNITS TO TRANSFER
SO THEREFORE THEY HAVE TO TAKE
THE WHOLE.
THE WHOLE COURSE OVER AGAIN SO
SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT THAT EASY
TO TRANSFER OVER -- THAT'S WHY I
STRONGLY FEEL THAT WE SHOULD GO
TO SOME TYPE OF COMPETENCY
TESTING WHEN THEY LOOK AT ANY
TYPE OF A LEARNED ABILITIES THAT
THEY'VE DONE OR ANY TYPE OF
COLLEGE CREDIT THAT IS IN ANY
MILITARY BRANCH I THINK THAT
THAT'S IT'S IT'S RESPECTING WHAT
THEY'VE LEARNED.
IT'S ALSO NOT BASING THEIR
KNOWLEDGE ON ON WHAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY COMPLETE AND DO AS THIS
GENTLEMAN SAID WHEN YOU LOOK AT
EVEN NURSING I LEARNED MORE ON
HANDS THAN I EVER DID IN MY
NURSING COURSES I LEARNED ALL
THE BASIC THINGS BUT MY ON HANDS
TRAINING TAUGHT ME.
EVERYTHING AND I TAUGHT NURSING
BUT THERE'S NO REASON FOR ME TO
PUT.
A MEDIC OR CORPSMAN IN THAT
WHOLE FIRST SEMESTER OF NURSING
SCHOOL WHEN THEY'RE GONNA LEARN
HOW TO MAKE A BED AND PUT IN A
CATHETER.
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY DONE
FIVE MILLION OTHER THINGS
TRAIPSING YOU KNOW SO DO PEOPLE
UP WHEN THEY'RE ON THE FRONT
LINES AND DONE FIVE MILLION
OTHER THINGS.
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO ANALYZE
WHAT THOSE ARE AND MAYBE GIVE
THEM CREDIT FOR TAKING THE
COURSES IF THEY JUST PASS AN
EXAM OR THEY CAN MEET THE
REQUIREMENT OF THAT EXAM SO.
IT BECOMES A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAILED CONVERSATION WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THOSE
TRANSCRIPTS.
THANK YOU.
SURE WILL COME.
THANK YOU MISTER MADAM CHAI --
JUST A A QUICK CORTISOL HERE
BEFORE WE WRAP WITH THIS UP --
LAST YEAR WAS A GOOD YEAR FOR
THE VETERAN CENTER IS A TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE WITH
EVERYONE'S HARD WORKING
COOPERATION WE WERE ABLE TO GET
I BELIEVE THE NEXT -- FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
NOW.
COLLEAGUES HERE'S WHY THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU'RE
VETERANS CENTERS IS A PLACE FOR
SOME SHELL SHOCKED.
SAP LIKE ME TO GO AND JUST TALK
TO OTHER VETERANS AND YOUR OTHER
VETERANS WILL EITHER SQUARE YOU
AWAY OR FEEL SORRY FOR YA OR
WHATEVER COMBINATION YOU NEED AT
THE TIME.
AND THE REASON I BRING THIS UP.
IS THERE IS A A MISSING PART
HERE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN DO
ANYTHING AT THE STATE LEVEL OR
THE VA LEVEL COLLEAGUES.
BUT TWENTY TWO VETERANS COMMIT
SUICIDE EVERY DAY [inaudible]
AND MOST OF THE TIME IT'S
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THEY'RE
TRAPPED LIKE RATS THEY CAN'T.
GET WHATEVER THEY HAVE TO GET --
AND I POINT OUT THIS IS NOT.
DATA IT IS -- ENTERED TOTAL.
BUT IT IS ESTIMATED THAT WOMEN.
PER CAPITA COMMIT SUICIDE IT IS
65% HIGHER RATE THAN MEN.
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S HUMANOID REACTION TO PTSD
AND STRESS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
BUT RIGHT NOW NO ONE IN THE VA
IS RESEARCHING THAT. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE SO I'M LOOKING AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEVEL FOR YOU ALL TO
THINK AND EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
TO THINK WHAT WE CAN WHAT CAN WE
DO TO ADDRESS.
THE WOMEN SUICIDE RATE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING NEGLECTED
ANYWAY THAT'S ALL I HAD TO SAY.
ABOUT THAT I FELL I FEEL LIKE I
THE FOREST GUMP HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I JUST LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION THERE
ACTUALLY WAS A REPORT THAT CAME
OUT RECENTLY -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NUMBERS A VETERAN SUICIDE IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND I BELIEVE IT
WAS AB TWO FOUR TWO FROM --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH PROVIDED
THIS THE NUMBER FOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WAS SIX HUNDRED FORTY
VETERANS COMMITTED SUICIDE --
MOSTLY OLDER WHITE MALES WERE
THE POPULATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- THAT COMMITTED
SUICIDE AT THEIR HIGHEST RATES
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET THAT
REPORT TO YOUR OFFICE.
BUT I'VE I'VE ONE OF ALL OF OUR
SPEAKERS TODAY.
I THINK WE'VE GOT SOME GREAT
INSIGHT FROM YOU AND ALSO WANT
TO THANK CHAIRMAN DANA WHO HAD --
TO TO LEAVE BUT HE WANTED TO
MEET ALSO OVERLAY THAT HE'S VERY
APPRECIATIVE OUR SPEAKER SO --
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE A
CHANCE NOW FOR OF PUBLIC
COMMENTS SO -- WE HAVE TWO
MINUTES -- FOR PUBLIC
[inaudible]
COMMENTS.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES VERY
BRIEFLY I WOULD SAY WHEN YOU
IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE WHEN YOU
CONTRAST THE DEDICATION THE
SACRIFICE OF VETERANS AND THE
BUSINESS PRACTICES THEY'RE
SUBJECTED TO UNDER LOOPHOLES --
OR OTHER ASPECTS OF LAW THAT
HAVE YET TO BE ADDRESSED.
I JUST WANTED TO ASK OUR SUPPORT
FOR SOME OF THE BILLS --
REFERENCED EARLIER TODAY THAT
ADDRESS -- DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT OF THESE BUSINESS --
PRACTICES ON VETERANS -- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE BILLS GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS LIKE THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS -- FOR CONVENING
THIS HEARING TODAY THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS -- RICHARD BENSON I AM A
STUDENT AT CARRINGTON COLLEGE
SACRAMENTO CAMPUS AND I JUST I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE.
MY SUCCESS THAT I'VE ACTUALLY
HAD WITH USING THE GI BILL --
SINCE GETTING OUT IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN I WAS ABLE.
TO NOT ONLY GO THROUGH THE
POLICE ACADEMY AND NAPA -- BUT
ALSO KNOCK OUT A FEW.
GENERAL ED CLASSES THAT
TRANSFERRED OVER TO US TO
CARRINGTON COLLEGE.
AND SINCE THEN I AM ABOUT SIX
WEEKS AWAY FROM GRADUATING.
ANDI HAVE ZERO STUDENT LOANS
AND I FEEL THAT HAVING THIS GI
BILL HAS BEEN A HUGE SUCCESS FOR
ME AND IT'S HELP ME KEEP MY LIFE.
ON TRACK SINCE GETTING OUT.
AND THE FACT THAT I DON'T HAVE
ANY STUDENT LOANS AND I'M ABOUT
TO GRADUATE AND GO INTO A FIELD
WHERE I ALREADY HAVE A JOB
[inaudible]
IS.
AMAZING AND I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE THAT LITTLE EXPERIENCE
WITH CARRINGTON HOW THEY'VE
ALWAYS THEY'VE BEEN VERY.
SUPPORTIVE AND NEVER PUSHY WITH.
WITH THE THE GI BILL OR ANYTHING
AND THEY'VE ALWAYS HAD MY BACK
MATTER WHAT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S --
LURKERS AND I CURRENTLY GO TO
SCHOOL AT YOU WE AYE AND
STOCKTON I PREPARED A LITTLE
SPEECH I'D LIKE TO GIVE -- I
SERVED IN THE NAVY FROM
200-022-00010 -- AFTER COMING
HOME IN TWO THOUSAND TEN I FELT
THAT -- I WAS PRETTY MUCH IS
DUMPED -- I EDUCATION MILITARY
DIDN'T TRANSFER OVER -- ABOUT
LOST -- RECENTLY I WAS HOME WITH.
LET ME HELP AFFRONT TO THERE
OUGHT.
TO DO IS MAKE -- I SUFFER FROM
PTSD -- FROM THIS ORDER THE
MILITARY.
WITHOUT THE GI BILL OR WHEN YOU
HEARD THAT RIGHT NOW -- I'M BACK
ON MY FEET OF WATER SCHOOL FULL
TIME.
NO NOT THE SCHOOL PUSH FOR ME TO
COME NO ONE IS SAID -- YOU KNOW
COME HERE WILL GIVE YOU THIS
WILL GIVE YOU THAT THEY GAVE ME
FAX.
I'VE LOOKED INTO UNIVERSITIES OF
LOOKED INTO YOU KNOW. FOUR YEARS
OF WORK IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OF LIKE TEN TO THE TRADE SCHOOL
[inaudible]
AND THE TRICK WAS GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK ON MY
FEET. TO SUPPLY FOR MY FAMILY.
WITHOUT THEM I WOULDN'T BE WHERE
I'M AT RIGHT NOW -- YOU KNOW
I'VE GOT THE HOUSE I GOT MY
FAMILY OUT FROM A GARAGE.
BURNING CARS ARM.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ME
MIGHT BE JUST THE ALONG WITH MY
MY SURGERY TO HAVE COME UP WITH --
THE VERY ACCOMMODATING -- AND I
DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
RESTRICTED OR WHERE WE CAN GO TO
SCHOOL OUT OR HOW WE GO TO
SCHOOL I THINK THAT'S A RIGHT
THAT WE'VE EARNED -- COULD
CHOOSE WHERE WE GO TO SCHOOL AT
WHEN WE GO TO SCHOOL ON I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY CAN'T GO
WHY SHOULD I BE PUNISHED BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY YOU KNOW PEOPLE
AT THE SCHOOL -- I THINK IT
SHOULD BE MANDATED AT A HIGHER
RATE YOU KNOW A FIRE ON THE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OUT THERE TO
YOU KNOW JUST DOUBTS.
AS VETERANS UNDERSTAND OUR
SCHOOLS LIKE THAT OUT THERE --
WELL I GUESS THAT WITHOUT YOU WE
I WOULD BE WHERE I'M AT TODAY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN MY NAME IS GERRY
PLASTER -- I SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS FOR
YEARS -- I CURRENTLY ATTEND YOU
WE AYE IN STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AND I KIND OF WANTED JUST
TO SPEAK ON MY SUCCESS AS WELL --
I AM CURRENTLY IN THE SEVENTH
MONTH OF MY NINE MONTH PROGRAM.
I HAVE BEEN FULLY EMPLOYED AFTER
FIVE MONTHS OF BEING IN THE
PROGRAM -- WITH A FULL TIME JOB
ALSO GO TO SCHOOL FULL TIME AS
WELL I HAVE TWO MONTHS OF SCHOOL
LEFT WITH NO WITH NO. FOR NO
STUDENT LOANS.
AND I'M ALREADY WORKING IN MY
FIELD AND AFTER MY TWO MONTHS I
WILL BE.
FULL TIME AND I WILL ALSO BE
HAVING MY OWN.
MY OWN CAREER PATH -- TEN UP I
DEFINITELY CHANGED.
MY LIFE IN THE FACT THAT I HAVE
GOALS AND I HAVE A CAREER PATH
NOW.
BEFORE -- YOU GET OUR MILITARY
WITHOUT HAVING A HARD TIME
TRANSITIONING DUE TO THE FACT
THAT A LOT OF MY EXPERIENCE IT
MY EXPERIENCES WERE NOT WAS NOT
BEING.
TRANSFERRED OVER TO THE CIVILIAN
SECTOR -- ACTUALLY -- MISS
MONTGOMERY WAS STATING -- A LOT
OF A LOT OF WHAT I WAS DOING --
I NEEDED -- WAS THE KEY WORD FOR
THAT -- I NEEDED A THANK.
I CAN'T REALLY THINK OF IT RIGHT
NOW -- BUT YEAH -- SO GIVEN THE
THAT UP I WAS SO ACCOMMODATING
THEY DIDN'T SEEK OUT MY MY GI
BILL ACTUALLY SOUGHT THEM OUT.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT IT WAS A
NINE MONTH PROGRAM AND I WAS
ABLE TO QUICKLY GET INTO -- A
CAREER PATH AND I WAS ABLE TO
SET STRAIGHT AHEAD IS STRAIGHTEN
ME OUT SO I'M REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE UP I PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN --
MEMBER AT HOWARD FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LOS -- CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INCIDENT ALSO PRIVILEGED.
TO REPRESENT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THE VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC HEADED
BY.
MR ME WITH -- A THANK YOU AND
AND AND OBSERVATION THANK YOU IS --
TO THE CHAIRS THE STAFF OF THESE
COMMITTEES AND TO THE THE
STATEMENTS OF ALL OF THE MEMBERS
THAT WERE HEARD TODAY -- YOURS
MADAM CHAIR AND YOURS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS ABOUT
TRYING TO PUT AN END TO THESE
PROBLEMS ONCE AND FOR ALL -- IT
IS THIS HEARING I THINK IS THE
ONE THAT HAS PROVIDED ME THE
MOST OPTIMISM IN OVER TWENTY
YEARS OF FOLLOWING THIS ISSUE --
AND I I WILL OBSERVE THAT ONE OF
THE FACETS IN PART OF SOLVING
THIS ONCE AND FOR ALL.
IS PREVENTING POOR QUALITY
INSTITUTIONS FROM GETTING
APPROVED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND THAT'S WHAT SIX OF THE SEVEN
BILLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY PENDING --
IN THIS HOUSE FIVE OF THEM I
BELIEVE ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ARE ALL ABOUT.
THE SECOND IS THE OBSERVATION --
WE HEARD ONE PIECE OF WHAT I
THINK IS QUITE REMARKABLE
TESTIMONY -- FROM ASSISTANT
DEPUTY SECRETARY -- JOHNSON WHO
PARENTHESES IS IS ONE OF THE
MOST OUTSTANDING PUBLIC SERVANTS
ARE THE PRIVILEGE TO MEET.
TWENTY YEARS APPEAR AND
APPRENTICE -- THAT SHE SAID HER
EFFORTS SIMPLY TO VERIFY.
THE INFORMATION PROVIDED TO
STUDENTS AS WELL AS REGULATORS
ABOUT SCHOOL PERFORMANCE AS
BEING TRUE.
WAS BEING INTERFERED WITH BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NOW I AM NOT A VETERAN.
I STAND IN HUMBLE ALL.
OF THOSE WHO HAD THE BRAVERY TO
SIR.
BUT I AM A TAXPAYER.
AND THAT MAKES ME ANGRY.
AS A TAXPAYER AS A TAXPAYER I
DESERVE.
VIGILANT SUPERVISION OVER HOW MY
TAX MONEY IS SPENT.
AND IT UNDERSCORES AGAIN THE
NEED FOR THE SEVEN BILLS.
CALIFORNIA HAS TO CHART ITS OWN
COURSE HERE WITHOUT A THANK YOU
FOR A TRULY FANTASTIC HERE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED